what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
as always I'm just checking in on you
seeing all your life's going and we
already did the two shot we have an
amazing guest here uh one of my favorite
people and musicians and bands Josh
Homme from uh Queens of the Stone Age
who says do not promote his album but
I'm gonna because I love this album in
Times New Roman
I can't I'm like that's almost like my
dyslexia almost like that almost Roman
in time so I'm like is that how it is no
it's in Times New Roman and I've been
listening to this thing uh I don't know
if you noticed but I'm back in the gym I
don't know if you noticed a little more
you're looking really hot um I only have
a double cheeseburger left here I got
rid of the Wendy's Triple we're working
our way down at a dinner you were
looking really trim it's like who is
this hot guy and I was like that's bill
you're like am I looking in a mirror and
I aged 40 years oh wait that's that
gentleman named Bill but this album I'm
just gonna I'm gonna get past the
compliments and then you can get yeah
that's gonna make me uncomfortable
anyways all right it's I'll do it to you
if you do it to me so watch Twitter I'll
[__] take that I'm vain
um it's one of those albums I listened
to it right the first time I was like
two songs that really grabbed me and
then I was like I don't think I'm smart
enough for this album and then three of
them in I'm like this [__] album's
unbelievable and now it's just playing
on a loop on the elliptical into the car
and it just keeps going and uh I I I
like it's you guys are really one of the
most unique nobody sounds like you guys
and then every time I think I know what
your sound is you come up with a new
album and you change it a little bit and
then I gotta try to catch up well you
know you have to you have to you know
ideally someone hears you and within a
few seconds they know it's you even
though there's that change there uh-huh
you know because and I appreciate you
saying that and and it's supposed to be
a 50th listen thing yeah because there's
some things you hear them a few times
you're like I got it I'm good
the first time you're gonna hate it by
the third time right it's just it's sort
of gonna run its core it's gonna be like
Fruit Stripe that that gum where you're
like first four pumps of that is [__]
amazing and then it is you're like this
is the greatest gum I've ever had within
47 seconds you're like who the f what
the [__] happened I have bad breath
again yeah like what the [__] happened
to this again you're right and and so
ideally it's there
much like that submersible it goes
really deep everything about it and then
it then it crushes itself oh I missed
that oh yeah I'm always big on deep dark
I do that bit the night you came out you
did you actually did a great bit that
night yes I hate that there's have you
been working that bit or is that that
was just because that was one of those
ones that just came out
um
I I kind of liked I like the idea of
these billionaires going down to look at
you know what should have been dead
billionaires but they got off yeah they
were looking like women and children
third yeah who would have worked for me
120 years ago they went down to look at
that and then they end up like dying and
then I also found I also loved how
everybody you know on social media
because it is such a me thing made the
story about themselves and what they
would have done and how they never would
have got on the thing and all of that
type of stuff and then you know there
was some race thing there well this is
like white people problems it was a lot
well then there was also like you know
your armchair Engineers were like the
carbon fiber that was that you know
where where people are like critiquing
the build I still don't get the weight
of water on you it's like I'm in it man
I'm part of it yeah you know what I mean
it's like I get if a safe is on me but
there's something that it's a liquid
that it also at the lower you go the
pressure of the yeah yeah and it took me
forever to understand air pressure in
air but now like water it's just like
wait so like all pressure and air as it
pertains like flying choppers and yes it
took me a while to figure that out what
wait what is the wind what happens in a
heavy wind with a chopper that seems I'm
terrified by going diagonal well it
depends on uh like what what it but what
are you thinking when you hit a high
wind and you're like ah I mean turn from
joystick to like no joystick well I've
only had experienced severe turbulence a
couple of times and we just landed and
your thoughts were
we need the land
because well we were in what we were in
was a light helicopter and then it was
just a two-bladed under slung system so
you could have like a mass bump so what
you're supposed to do when that happens
is you slow down if you're flying 90
knots you go down to like 60 you slow
down and then you decide from you kind
of let the wind do what it wants to you
don't fight it yeah but you don't try to
correct into it and you don't fight yeah
and what about things like you know
you're on a plane you hit a pocket where
you drop or the pressure changes in a
helicopter that's see that's like that's
where I would be like this is where I
ship my pants right or is this where I
should in your pants because I'm no it's
still it's all like what you have to
understand is that the the the rotor
blades are shaped just like wings it's
the same shape and it's the same
principle
it's just the engine makes them you know
is making them move where this the plane
is stationary that's why you need all
that forward movement to maintain lift
and that's why we can hover right but
when do I shut my pants all the whole
time anytime you run a light aircraft
you you are [__] your pants yeah
you're like oh that's just coming off
the mountains that's totally normal yeah
there's like a lot of cross rubbing and
like a little bit no no you know what I
have I have this app it's called windy
and you click on Wendy and then you just
it just showed us sort of everyone knows
it's windy yeah everybody knows it's
windy and there's a certain amount of
it's not even not to it's what it really
is is gusting that's what's scary what
it's like eight knots Gusty yeah the
unexpected gusts yes so that that's life
when it can get scared but I fly a fully
articulated main rotor system so I don't
have to worry about Mass bumps and low G
pushovers however it is a light aircraft
I fly when it's that makes whole sense
to me right I fly when it's nice out all
right
one of the things that I do
to do is not talk to people who don't
fly about Aviation because all you ride
a motorcycle yes is there anything
better than talking to somebody who also
rides yes oh fantastic you're talking
about the flying Gap so what happens is
it's not fun no people all they do is
talk about you dying that's all they
have to bring motorcycles it's just like
oh you know because of that you lost the
leg everybody says you but it's not a
matter if it's a matter of when might as
well buy a coffin with that [__]
thing and it's just like they do the
same so that's all I can because it is
I'm already bringing the [__] in your
pants thing to the table because all I
have to give
but you'll also like ride a motorcycle
in Los Angeles when everyone's like on
some sort of legalized weed looking at
their phones totally and going over the
double line and and I love the focus of
it because you might die I love that I
don't some people have like headphones
for the like Susie should we stop and
get something you know they're talking
to their right their significant other
on the back of the uh not me or they're
listening to music not me I'm just right
you know now are you up I like the focus
that if you're the one going the fastest
you only have to worry about what's in
front of you that's exactly right that's
what people do you also got the bigger
bike with the bags and I feel like well
I have a cup I have a couple and there's
a couple lane splitting but it is
important to get to the front so people
don't have to notice you right so at any
you know getting faster and also you
have to learn to throttle through
trouble which is a really scary notion
there's some pants [__] there too
I am the biggest
not owning a motorcycle guy a motorcycle
guy you're ever going to meet and I Oh
you mean you like the idea but it's just
too no I I had one for like I always
tell a story I had one like six weeks
and uh I had a Triumph Bonneville and I
loved it and all I wanted to do is go
from Sunset take it all the way out to
the beach yeah just that was my first
ride that I wanted to do and you know
somebody came over the double line when
I was in a turn and I had to come up you
know just for a split second but it felt
like I was going to go right into the
[__] trees or lose my head and then
when I finally stopped to get gas like a
half hour later I got off but I noticed
I was sort of shaking and I was like is
that from the vibration of the engine
and it was just like oh no that's
because I thought I was gonna die so
then I did something I never do is I
prayed to God
please don't let but and I said yes if
you let
you let Raj I will never ride it again
and I never did but recently in April I
went to the Moto GP race at Coda sorry
of the Americas and we were talking
about going to the Isle of of man to do
the TT to check out the TT and I was
even suggesting we get a chopper that we
could hover over the race somehow like
add the skills of being a fan and your
skill set you know yeah that would be uh
like that's all the bikes because they
go by so fast and you know they're
sheeps in the road
but literally is it sheep or sheeps well
I think there's probably more than one
no I don't know what is it it's cheap of
course but it sounds cute to say sheeps
[Music]
I had an ideal childhood you know I grew
up on a farm with a bunch of sheeps
[Music]
no but they do say no they say count
sheep not counting sheeps one of my
thing is not in my house my thing is my
favorite thing is people not only
[__] up sayings but combining them oh
my this is like like you're you're not
the smart he's he's not the smartest
he's not the smartest tool in the shed
it's the latest one I had it's not the
Shoppers tool in the show right this or
when someone says it's not rocket
surgery I said that yeah it isn't
Rockets yeah I write them down you want
to hear a few yeah let's do it okay
let's do this for uh for you and for
some of the listeners here
where are they I this now if I if I
actually had some sort of production
value this this would have been ready in
the interim while you're doing this I
gotta my mom does this all the time and
so she this is just totally lost him so
here we go okay give me one and then
I'll tell you about my the mom story
they should know each other like
clockwork
you were a piece of dirt that I wouldn't
piss on if you were on fire
uh he's not the brightest bulb to come
down the pipe no [__] Captain Obvious
that's another one worth the trade offer
yeah
feudal attempt versus feudal
feudal like Feud all right one last one
swear futile swears like a fish
well my mom has this problem where she
just naturally combines them and so she
said to my my dad the other day I I
don't you don't have to manscape to me
and I was like I was like also don't do
it to me as well I don't want my dad
manscaping anywhere explaining yeah yeah
that's it's clear it's like that's
pretty Progressive for her to even know
what that is right sure yeah manscape do
you know my my lovely wife Nia went to
go see the Barbie movie and she came
home and she told me how funny it was
and how awesome it was I was like I
would have loved to seen that with you
why didn't you take me she goes you're
too misogynistic for that moment and I
got mad for like [__] three minutes
and then I thought about Sarah and she's
right possibly but but in this hot hot
heat I'd almost sit through any movie
see I in the desert I love Ryan Gosling
so and Margot Robbie it's gorgeous
they're both gorgeous I'm just happy
that they casted somebody gorgeous yeah
I thought they were going to do that you
know yeah well yeah have you ever had
that guy that that played like sipowitz
on uh [__] NYPD Blue
yeah just like why why can't why can't
he play this part what's wrong with you
he should be able to dance right exactly
yeah shouldn't it be about the
performance it is and not his mustache
especially in the Barbie movie exactly
you know but see in this I growing up in
the desert in the summer when it's hot
like it is I didn't care what it was it
was just two hours in the dark in the
cold right you know so would you have
gone to see the Barbie movies would you
yeah I would have been I would have
ruined it for because that's what always
happens last movie I went to go see with
her was the whale which I kept calling
fat cell you want to go see Fatso just
because because just because it's so
stupidly inappropriate and how was it it
was fantastic and I loved it but she
gave me a whole speech before we went in
she goes no laughing in inappropriate
moments no making jokes and of course
the second I got in there I I was trying
to guess what the movie was going so
something struck me as funny and she was
cold and she was leaning on me so she
felt me going like this and then she got
chortling she got mad you know not mad
mad but got upset and she like went away
from me but fortunately it was so cold
in the theater when I took my jacket off
and gave it to her yeah it was it
brought it again I made it yeah you made
it back you made up your point it was a
fantastic movie and I absolutely loved
it totally think you know I love Brendan
Fraser and all that but I mean
I I think his uh his performance in
Encino Man was powerful but I guess I
never saw that coming that he would but
that that's the thing what I think
acting is so like whenever I do do an
acting gig and if somebody finds out I
do stand up they always say oh my God
that's like the hardest gig ever it's
like it isn't I am 100 in control sure
of what I have to do and what I have to
say and it's a bit one way in its own
way right it's a one-way conversation
it's really the control right so I can
stay totally within my comfort zone
that's also how you don't grow as a
comedian but I can just say like I don't
want to start singing up here because I
can't sing too good or anything like
that you get into an acting gig and it's
like whatever they wrote you basically
have to do and then you do it and you're
at the mercy of of the editor the the
music and all that and that and they can
literally make you go from okay to great
or if you did something great they can
drag it down that's what I'm saying
isn't it there's so many people involved
in making something like that it seems
so difficult to guarantee that your best
performance wouldn't be on a cutting
room floor or just it's of no
consequence for telling the broader
story and so you just sort of pissed
away all this hard work it just seems D
It's seems difficult and then you never
prove yourself as an actor I feel like
they just you have you just constantly
going I want to play that role well can
you play that role Tech I want a [__]
Oscar yeah and it's just like well you
know that you won it in the 2000s yeah
yeah so shouldn't I be never over 13
years better and it's just like just
watching them like like I don't once I
go into a club and I come in and I'm a
nice guy and I killed I didn't have to
resend him a tape the next year to see
if I could come here it's just like I
had proven I was funny and I feel like
as an actor you just have to you just it
never ends do you think you're at the
point now in this acting situation where
you can
are do you feel you're comfortable
enough to like yeah I see this green
Direction I do this but you you get
you're having enough input and the stuff
that you're doing or is it still oh no I
just do what I do and if the director
doesn't like it I just go well what do
you want me to do yeah right give me a
line read I don't give a [__] yes let's
just get what you want and let's go home
let's get out of here like that's my
number one thing I want to be on the set
be on time know all my lines and
whatever the director tells me to do I'm
like all right I'll do that well it's
weird directing is one of the last
autonomous jobs
you know where you can be you're kind of
a dictator of the situation you know you
understand
the overarching need that you have like
the total needs yeah to make something
it's there's not a lot of jobs
that are that much in control of an
entire situation certainly getting that
gig one time and how did that go
for wait for what I'm not allowed to say
man because of the strike oh really okay
I'm not allowed to strike one yeah so I
I directed something that's that is
unknown could ever come out at some
point and I'm not allowed to say when oh
well that sounds great so uh wait I want
to talk about the homeless guy that you
almost hit with your car the other day
that entered the ACT
because we were at dinner we were
talking about uh we were sharing a
smoothie
two straws two curly straws with shamos
on them from SeaWorld yeah uh one cup
and uh we were talking about not neat
wanting to not need to use your act
but oh yeah and and and just picking up
things oh yeah I was talking about how
uh especially on on a night because we
went to dinner and then afterwards I had
a show at the Adam Ray Show where he was
being Dr Phil Dr Phil
um at the main room at the store so it's
like I had to go out and do a stand-up
set so in something like that people are
not paying to see me so I'm gonna try
out new stuff so on those nights it's
all about like you're not needing to use
your ass avoiding your act right but so
we almost hit a homeless guy that was
really frankly
not too afraid of any of the cars on the
road he wasn't aware he was in the road
right but he was sort of like
yeah I mean but he was sort of like ah
you know I mean and Man vs car it's
always a car that wins but he was and he
was sort of jig jagging or whatever we
ended up having to go different ways
around because he was so and then you
ended up opening with with a bit about
that guy about that guy I was saying
yeah and I was like that's my boy
because
I was saying that car up from the sewers
and this country's gonna and it's so
awful they got mental illness and I
really built it in an empathetic way and
I said this this com this country is
going to change as we start welding
those manhole covers
like the John Carpenter uh movie They
Live did you ever see that one the one
with Rowdy Roddy Piper
is that the one I've chewed bubblegum
I'm all on bubblegum all that and
there's like a 15 minute fight scene
it's so long
there's just it's got a nod to pro
wrestling it's so good because it's
really it's very current in its okay
story because it's about the marketing
and propaganda but it's done by aliens
and they're constantly marketing and you
know again we all sort of collectively
agree that there are aliens now yeah I'm
pretty sure is that what happened yeah
Build That Wall or no way no no
not the Trump ones that he was talking
about yeah I mean because he didn't
realize Liberals are the greatest pirate
right yeah yeah that's already yeah we
had already built it and thrown them in
jail yeah and then he got blamed for the
whole [__] thing like yeah he was the
first guy well but the our greatest
Pilots our true Top Gun Pilots have all
seen did you see the one where it's this
thing descends and shoots right into the
ocean it is it was our greatest pilot
was like what the [__] and they're
seeing it on the radar
I've never seen yeah
can we pull up a picture of a weather
balloon because when I was growing up
it's the weather balloon it's uh the
refraction of the light I love that that
would work though someone would say this
high speed moving object that's moving
in a way that's beyond all all
technology and it's like yeah well it's
a weatherboard and someone would go oh
or military technology that that that
they have that they know about but for
our own security
we don't for your own good yeah it's for
your own good that you accept that it's
a weather bloom do you think now that
they've found out that there's a whole
bunch of other Earths do you think that
God is sort of looking at it like which
Earth is going to win who really he's
got a pocket full of ones up there with
the devil just like doing a gambling
thing
he needs to devil yeah you need
something by the way of course you know
what I mean if everybody's sat around
and [__] agreed with them of course
bored shitless yeah you had to invent
someone to argue with him he invented
conflict right so you know so there's
that hunts
it's all it's a ball washing every
Sunday it's all the beautiful stuff that
he did not all the [__] up stuff do
you know to let them know what a good
day is you know to tell Abraham to kill
his son that was kind of a dick move and
then to be like nah just kidding oh
you're neighbors Abraham's just like oh
God you know this oh it's a weather
balloon oh well I mean it looks just
like a flying saucer right down the
bottom
well there you go there you go that's
what it is wait no wait a second why is
Mida believe it's that high
okay all right I believe it Aaron just
goes yep yeah yeah that was so like
that's not uh that's not photoshopped
okay but why isn't that the biggest
story in the world that's how you know
how [__] up the world has gotten is
that the UFO and the government saying
yeah okay yeah because I don't think
there's enough people focused on any one
thing anymore but how is that not the
biggest I mean yeah
it's the biggest why isn't that the ever
all everyone they gotta get they gotta
give people a chance to write the third
Testament
and then adjust the story and say no but
God did give us the third Testament you
guys just weren't ready for it and here
it is yes from a weather balloon over
Florida yes dropping down and still God
loves us the best yeah and we still pray
to White Jesus I love it you know the
funny thing about the Bible is that it
does start out with uh I mean incest
I mean that's the only way it kind of
Adam and Eve it'd be like I like that we
all came out of the ocean like you know
when the turtles little turtles go into
the ocean they get eaten by the birds I
like that we all came out
how would that work though I mean so if
you're a fish and you're just like I
want to go on land and you try and you
die and someone else is like did you see
what Gary just did I want to try too and
eventually it works is that what happens
you know what kills all my points
follow-up questions
yeah well how would that work you know
what I don't know I have no idea
um I I kind of I you know then there's
that Neil deGrasse Tyson who I feel like
is mainstream smart right I don't buy
that this guy said he's smart yeah he's
just talking to people we wouldn't know
right so you wouldn't know you don't get
to get you just it's like you're talking
to regular people like wow you're really
funny but unless the comedians I've
never seen a scientist say you know that
Neil deGrasse Tyson well wow I think
plus he is he wears sort of an ascot
type of thing sometimes he's doing some
of the fashion moves that it would make
to Dr Phil Vibe yeah yeah where Dr Phil
was a therapist and at some point that
just helping people board him and he was
like I want my own TV show and groupies
yeah and then yeah so at that point then
he has the same disease I have which is
just that you you gotta need like a
crowd to be like applauding you when you
walk out see you don't [__] kill
yourself some kind of confirmation that
you're headed in the right direction by
the audience
yeah I just picture him like well like
his former patients I just want to be
like when he had hair and he was talking
how did that go did he feel bored that
he wanted more there's got to be
something more than just doing this
one-on-one I want an all-female audience
and just you know for the most part
agree with the female perspective so I
can get like a big [__] house it's a
weird thing it's a weird thing and also
you're you're doing you're you're being
like well he's not the father
I mean that's what you're doing is like
doing those kind of Reveals All Day oh
that was yeah I mean it's a little bit
you know but that kind of daytime help
you know it's funny on the way over here
there was a guy in a Jeep Rubicon and he
had his spare tire cover
said one life live it
and I was sitting there going like oh we
hell yeah man were you that in the
moment when you bought that Jeep Rubicon
I was 100 present when they upsold me
from the Jeep Wrangler with that on
there that came with it it's like you're
welcome man you're welcome
like it's unsolicited life advice and
then also by having that on your car
you're suggesting that that's what
you're doing yeah you're you're yeah
you're you're all but guaranteeing that
being in the Rubicon is proof positive
like I'm doing man it's a little bit
like that's right I just wake up every
day it's the Counterpoint to the Bed
Bath and Beyond like it's wine 30. you
know all those towels that they have
like Mommy juice
you know like that's all for people
who've never been arrested in their life
it's like all of their yeah everything's
like comfy
and like soft and [__] like that but um
nasty it's very nasty very nasty I'm
nesting
I'm a foodie I'm an empath I'm an I'm on
my journey I'm on my journey I'm having
a cheat day yeah these are just all
excuses I'm having for being selfish and
just [__] actually cheat day sounds
like an amazing porn series
starved all week I'm having a cheat day
you didn't [__] me all week and now I'm
[__] banging somebody else oh my God
that's fantastic that's a great [__]
uh concept porno yeah but you know every
once in a while yeah there needs to be a
problem but they'll they try to have a
little bit of humor yeah and there needs
to be a problem in each porno that
they're selling and the person who's
cheating has to be a hundred percent
indignant yeah yeah I'm having my own
body shamey don't uh [__] what they
call what do they call it what's that
smart word when you're you don't [__]
around yeah don't monogamy shame me I'm
a Naga shame managa shame but not gonna
come home
something like that this is why I
believe
that polygamy oh I believe in aliens and
one life live it live it absolutely I
like when you have kids people always
say hey you got to take it in you gotta
enjoy it's like that's not possible
you can't have one kid freaking the [__]
out that you're trying to potty train
and then the other one's screaming about
their iPad and just soaking in a moment
there's no way to not be thinking like
at 8 30 they'll both be in bed you know
when you have just like a little bit of
baby [__] on your cheek somehow
like after all you've done and you look
up and you're like oh my God now you've
just made it bigger you just really have
to just take that in yeah present yeah
yeah because you know that's just gonna
like you know it's gonna go by so fast
and it's just like look this everybody's
if you have kids It's Gonna Fly by and
no matter no matter how much time you
spend with them you're not gonna feel
like you spent enough so these [__]
people who have older kids they put this
[__] pressure on you that this is
[__] that they can't even live up to but
have you got to the point yet where so
Nostalgia is not my favorite thing
because uh you know yeah it's a little
bit of a bummer but have you gotten to
the point yet your kids are now getting
a little older six three three where you
take your with your six-year-old and you
see you know the two-year-old shoe and
you just hold that shoe and you're like
no you haven't got to that spot yet
either [__] that it's not real no I
don't do that because I started so late
so the fact that they're getting older
you know and I feel like thank God we
can finally start to do something no I
haven't died yet I'm like okay this is
good this is still time but I also like
uh
because I just a little shoe it's
amazing it's just like a regular show
I've got a goddamn little shoe it's so
amazing Helix everybody
talk about how important a good night's
sleep is to having a good day I'll tell
you right now if I don't get eight hours
I'm calling someone a [__] within the
first 20 minutes you can believe that
it's not true but you know just figured
I'd go big
I thought he was still there
um the Helix lineup offers 20 unique
mattresses including the award-winning
Luxe collection the newly released Helix
Elite collection and match a mattress
designed for Big and Tall sleepers even
a mattress made just for kids who would
have thought you know
I thought they were still sleeping on
the floor Eric
so how will you know which Helix
mattress works best for you and your
body everybody everybody is unique and
everyone sleeps differently that's why
Helix has several different mattress
models to choose from each design for
specific sleep positions and feel
preferences
models with memory foam layers to
provide optimal pressure relief if you
sleep on your side models with a more
responsive foam to cradle your body for
essential support in the stomach
the stomach and the back sleeping
positions
oh if you lay on your front is what
they're saying they didn't want to say
your dick plus enhanced cooling features
to keep you from overheating at night
plus Helix mattresses all come with a 10
to 15 year warranty depending on the
model don't want to take my word for it
don't worry about it Helix hasn't has
been awarded the number one mattress
pick by GQ and Wired Magazine it is even
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep
do you think they say that when they're
picking up chicks and what do you do I'm
a doctor of sleep medicine
Alex is offering 25 percent off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners in honor of Labor Day
go to helixsleep.com and use the code
Helix partners25 this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now
h-e-l-i-x-p-a-r-t-n-e-r-2-5 there's this
guy Brian the boot maker he's like a 26
year old cobbler oh downtown downtown
one day we went in when I just had my
daughter uh my son wasn't born yet I
went in with my lovely wife and we all
got we all got like boots made by him
and of course you know she grew out of
hers and I saw those I did see it in
like a week I know I did see those but
it's amazing a little shoe that has all
the same work in it is so [__] cute
and just but I did look I did look at it
the other day yeah and I was just like
what because I remember when I did
um one of my specials I remember because
we have a picture of it like she was
wearing those and I was wearing the ones
that Brian had made and we were in
[__] Royal Albert Hall yeah oh yeah
all right this is kind of a keeper plus
that venue that there's that venue is so
[__] classic I know you have the boot
you have the venue you got the thing
don't you feel like like I I I really
have to have I have to do something
special tonight I just can't just be
like a for sure you know for sure in
fact I'm surprised I sang okay tonight
well I had probably the best show I've
ever been part of at the Royal Albert
Hall too because that especially that
that's one of those venues that's just
this ball history and a special we play
we played it with Iggy you know when
we're he's backing band and it's one of
those things where and they're filming
it and usually when you're filming
something like that at a concert it's
not your best show because it's just
it's not but that was just like one of
those moments where everything now how
did you feel afterwards were you just
like honestly honestly I went I went I
had my own little dressing room and I
went in there and I kind of balled my
ass out that's good I I it was so I was
like wow that's awesome I I can't
believe I was
allowed to be part of that that guy in
the Jeep Rubicon would give you the
thumbs up
it was just such an amazing moment and I
I listened to Iggy since I was a kid and
he and I never played had he ever played
there no but he always wanted to he's
always under it was on his list of
things he wanted to do I was like tell
me 10 things you wanted to do that that
hadn't maybe hadn't curtain we'll see
let's see how many we can tick off yeah
that's another reason why he's so
amazing because he's talented enough
that he could have wrote some [__] that
would have got him there but he still
had to write what he wanted to write
well it's interesting because like being
been playing with him I realized a few
things that was like a you know I've
always tried to
do my own thing and and not be overly
influenced but not deny your influences
you know and
um wanting to sound like yourself and
taking those risks is about taking those
risks but Iggy is one of those guys that
the Stooges weren't just a little ahead
of their time people hated them actively
because they didn't understand them at
the time right 30 years it took for one
of those right for for raw power to go
gold even 30 years imagine I realized
when you're 30 years ahead of your time
it's lonely and you question yourself
right I know what I what I did I felt
was right and I and it's just not
understood yet I know it was like this
it's actually a lonely you were telling
me Summer Love and he's like now wow
Wanna Be Your Dog right and everyone is
like you know come home people now smile
yeah and he's like got a dog collar on
it's like being that far ahead of your
time there's a loneliness
associated with that and to not give in
to the doubts you have about your
direction
I just admire that he you know and uh
yeah how do you handle that like with
the way you guys change every album the
album you guys have so many critics like
this isn't what they already did yeah
and then they just [__] [__] all over
it and then if you stayed the same then
you've become a parody of yourself it's
like you can't like their job is to take
the piss out of it so they're gonna no
matter what you do I've completely
um
um I don't read anything and I haven't
for years because I I I
by the time we're finished making it I
know I put everything into it and I know
it's either a success or not based on
what happened there and I don't want to
let I don't want to get affected by
especially nowadays everyone's there are
people writing about something they've
never [__] done in their life and
giving this heavy critique of like you
know of something that sounds like half
of my ACT
well but that is the comment you know I
was in a way I almost wonder if comedy
hasn't really having this Golden Era
where it's it's really relevant and
important and it always was to me that I
right because you know you're talking
about
the difficult things in life by laughing
you know making fun of something where
making fun while there was none if you
can't make fun of Hitler then what are
you supposed to do just and enjoy taking
him seriously well it's it's yeah but
it's also like humor is like total
defense mechanism like I'm just gonna
make a joke so I don't have to feel the
real feeling but it's also a way to
Broach subjects that are difficult in a
way that there's an easy intro to the
conversation you know I was like I I you
know and and and I don't know from my
perspective almost like comedy's in this
great spot where it seems to have more
social relevance right now than even
loss of music does it you know music
that's taking on difficult subjects
quickly gets I I I imagine quickly gets
sort of like critiqued and torn apart
into all this but I think but there's so
much going on like there's a lot there's
like songs that I listen to for 30 years
and then finally really listen to the
lyrics right because I was just so
listening to the drummer the guitar
player Waylon and then I was going is
that what the [__] this song is about
like I love it from the Block yeah Jenny
From the Block I used to half listen to
it going like yeah she's not about money
and she's like listen all of this [__]
she's totally about money and then I
really Listen to It's like oh she
already owns all this stuff
oh this is like a feminist anthem
I thought it was like about Storage Wars
I thought it was just about like
somebody who was materialistic thinking
about I don't need this and I don't
think that's like well how do you know
you already know about all that [__]
well you are you are tapping into the
beautiful part about music is that you
get there are these levels and you get
to sort of enjoy that outer level
without having to go deep on it and it
can last for years yeah and there's
still this undercurrent there's more to
be had if you want it you know that's
why I like you know you were talking
about our record that the more you
listen to the more you start to get and
peel the layers back yeah it's fun to
make something that has
that complexity possible to it yeah that
that because that's the way it was like
uh like back in the day when you didn't
have all your music with you all the
time which I love but like I just
remember I would be at school thinking
about the album that I wanted to go home
and play yeah just sit there and listen
to it and hopefully I could get through
enough of it without my older brother
coming in and flicking the [__]
needle off punching me in the shoulder
yeah doing all of that [__] what a
sweetheart and uh but it's funny that
something would actually work you you
can hear something and it gives you a
strange feeling that's akin to walking
away from a first date where you have
butterflies and you think about it right
and it actually triggers this emotion
where just listening to
um these notes and ideas and things
coming together gives you a feeling
where and you want to do it again it's
kind of there's an addiction to it it's
it's it's beautiful to me that that
actually is possible and works who are
you listening to right now that like is
anybody that's coming up that uh
they're suspend the Viagra boys I've
been listening to oh you told me about
them I was like I love that name yeah
and and um it's very sort of raw and
it's sort of
uh
loose and and um
self-aware right like it's and it's kind
of skewering culture but by admitting
like I'm kind of I'm kind of making fun
of this but it's me right it's it's
self-aware that singer Sebastian is
really self-aware and sort of uh free in
himself then there's a bit of that Iggy
and a bit of
and this is humor in it of course we
have Viagra boys because I noticed what
like with with your stuff there's always
there's a humor yeah or irony in a lot
of the stuff that you certainly like all
like the titles of the song on most of
them on this one but like uh
I always find like
like that type of stuff that like um
I I prefer like heavy [__] delivered in
a silly way yeah rather than a heavy
delivered heavy to me becomes like
redundant well there's a balance it
almost like upsets me well because it
also it can get cheesy REM yeah
everybody Hurts it's just like oh my god
dude right I get it it is true but it's
just like I wasn't you know it really
was because it's a great song I wasn't
comfortable you were ready to admit that
just to watch a man but I also think
singing like but aren't you talking
about there's some there's some things
when heavy I did everything but feel his
head on my shoulder when he was singing
that like all right all right all right
REM guys
yeah I just think that what I heard what
I if what I think what I'm hearing you
say is the delivery of something heavy
sometimes when it's too when it's all
too heavy it gets a little cheesy that's
why I can't watch Nate I can't watch
nature shows anymore
okay and there's [__] plastic bags
and all of this [__] you're like over a
beavers yeah it's just a Ziploc and all
the coral the Great Barrier Reef is
dying it's all turning white and nobody
gives a [__] you just like true now
what do I do now what do I do I'm going
to bed with this the Great Barrier Reef
is dying good night yeah good night oh
Lawrence well sleep tight
I've just decided that I'm I'm I'm now I
I uh how I'm combating all of this stuff
because all of this shit's freaking me
out it's hard not to be a little bit
freaked out I'm I am small town Billy I
just I just like I have just mind your
own backyard keep your focus tight and I
go down I got my place right by my paper
I get my Italian food here I get my cup
of coffee I don't worry about the rest
of it but I I maintain that maybe in a
way you shouldn't be worrying about the
rest of the world you should be only
focused on your immediate area if your
immediate area was the most important
thing which included like you know
voting for councilman that's my most
important vote right and cleaning up
your own backyard is Elvis thing and you
know I mean there's people are starving
across the world but
I feel like the news is trying to make
you feel bad about like something you
can't even participate in no it's like
this horrible thing is happening we have
no solution and good night and you can't
take your eyes off it yeah and keep
watching and we got you now and yeah and
unless unless you think Starving
Children is okay right where you're like
what the [__] what how did this even
happen what are you talking about I
didn't say anything have you seen that
clip Elvis gave the best [__]
response they go what do you think about
you know the war over there blah blah
and he's just like my own just the
Entertainer man I don't I don't I ain't
gonna talk about it what do you think
about people who have criticized the war
do you think that they shouldn't do it
he's like I'm not going to tell anybody
what the shooter shouldn't do I'm just
I'm just a guy who goes out there well
that's how I I've shot it up a little
bit that's kind of
did he really do no he didn't know about
I mean I would have loved it
more into this I think really yeah my
answer a little bang bang a little left
right in the middle I'm a Centrist
that's going to be words someday in the
future centers thank you very much
well but I I do see the value in
escapism like I don't [__] like to
engage in all that stuff in in what I do
because there needs to be video game
arcades and ice cream parlors where
you're like please just shut the [__] up
Gary I want to hear it somewhere is it
somewhere I don't have to hear yes all
this stuff from you can I just turn up
the music and it's why music should be
turned up it's so you can't talk yeah I
I just give you now it's designed to
fail so I'm just gonna [__] you know
enjoy I mean I mean you know what that
spare tire cover I'm gonna [__] you
know on mine one life and I'm gonna live
it you know what now I know to get you
for your birthday I'm gonna do my
elliptical in the morning have a flat
white and [__] read the newspaper and
[__] try to be nice to people well I
have I have a question too like you know
uh
there's a lot of comics out there that
really kind of aren't that great go to a
night on that like you were killing it
darker you were you were you were
killing but there's a lot of there's a
lot of stuff that uh
I would say it's hard and it's like
place in the journey and they're they're
on their way I mean there's a lot of VHS
tape of me not being funny at all well
right but so what I mean by that what I
mean
sweaty and unfun what I mean is like in
that wood shopping phase
like that process seems so difficult
when you're there's a lot of comedians
that seem like they're still
developing their thing and the notion of
getting up there and bombing all the
time
how does that work well you have to
build I mean that takes a lot of
potassium foreign
first thing you have to do is you have
to build I just kind of admire that
actually to going up failing and going
back up and getting up again and again
and again oh yeah because it takes a
I mean to do that 10 times in a row
isn't that what it is you're gonna talk
me out of doing stand up if you if you
keep bringing the logic into this
um
I you have to bit like the club has to
to really go up and bomb and grow you
you have to have killed I feel for like
two three years not maybe a couple year
and a half two years they know you're
funny so then if they see you up there
bombing then they know you're trying to
grow through something like yeah like
okay we got to stop giving this guy at
these Primo spots or whatever so
um there is like different kinds of
bombing there's like bombing because
you're new and you don't know what
you're doing right and then there's then
once you start to know what you do
you're doing then there's I lost them
what the [__] happened right I had them
mid-flight like I've lost my gauges
what's happening here and then there's
that bombing which you may or may not
recover but you don't 100 know how to
get them back and then I feel like the
last phase is like if I wanted to I
could kill with this [__] that I know
that works but that that's that's why
yeah that's what we're not even to rely
on your act right but it's a waste of a
drive over here because my ACT isn't
going to grow or going like a different
direction or anything I just remember
going to the desert and
going to see Rodney Dangerfield I was
like 10 years old 9 years old with my
folks and uh I'd already seen Carlin
before at nine because my dad was in
Vegas in at the desert in same place
Fred travalina opened up and Judy tenuto
opened up for uh the rest of the soul
man I loved her yeah
and accordion is funny by Nature because
look at the thing right yeah yeah
[__] pig she was like and she was
amazing yeah and then but Rodney came
out and he did you know he really was
leaning heavy on the old a lot of old
bits and he got booed off stage and I
was only nine I never I didn't know you
could boost up that that was at nine you
have no concept that like if it's not
going well the audience is allowed to
say the word boo until so watching
someone get booed and then he was like
[__] you and he left I was like
is this part of the show am I
can somebody help me to understand like
I had to ask my folks what does that
even mean and then I realized the
Jeopardy of going on stage that you are
like you're taking this big risk you
know yeah there's uh it was odd to see
that and know that that adults can boo
each is this how does that work you know
because but what was great back then is
he got booed at the Desert Inn and the
only people that knew it were the ones
in that room yeah and that's something
that I I do miss about
um
the time I got booed one of them many
times but the one that got filmed
that was early on in uh sort of social
media
uh on the open Anthony tour that came it
was 0506 or something like that
and I was worried like my career was
over right because I was just like oh my
God like everyone's gonna boo me now
because they're going to want to see me
like Snap which is what happened the
next weekend including was this the snap
and it was it a Philadelphia thing or
something that that was the one well I
mean I've been booed before I've got
boot in Vegas
and a couple other times I mean it
happened but it was the first time I was
like actually filmed and uh yeah I
trashed their sports teams or whatever
but I I remember leaving
and the other comes oh my God you know
that was [__] so cool blah blah blah
and I was thinking like I I was like no
I don't think it was I think I just
ended my career and I was thinking like
and I remember the next well nowadays
that's forever on the permanent record
and held nothing ever disappears but
what I'm saying is that actually ended
up helping me right where you know but
that's not always going to be the case
yeah in the in cases of getting booed
off or having a meltdown or whatever I
think it all depends on like how you
like ended up handling it so then the
next week we went to Cleveland and they
booed me as I was walking on stage and
then I was just going like guys I'm not
you're not going to pretend to boomi and
then I'm gonna pretend to be upset right
and make fun of your thing and I started
doing my ACT they just kept doing and I
was just like all right good night so
that was weird and then I was convinced
that it was over then the next weekend I
I was off the tour and I did the punch
line in San Francisco and I was just
sitting in the back room and I was just
like what's going to happen are they
going to Boom anything but then I
realized wait this is like 180 people
there I can see all of them this isn't
ten thousand drunk people that just
disappear into darkness yeah so they
have the uh bravado
um I can eviscerate people here I'm in a
club I can see you so
um but I went through stuff like that
too where I would sort of you know sort
of all liquored up and you need to start
talking [__] to an audience and then
that gets online and then you have
people trying to go do into that you
know right
do you you know what the thing about
being in a band is I just feel like
where we get food people throw [__] at
you because they you can't hear what
they're saying because you're playing
your guitars and stuff for sure yeah so
I've had stuff thrown at me and just
something coming out from the light it's
just like it's like a becomes like a
major league pitcher because you don't
see it for the last four feet like this
thing's flying in your head and you're
out there don't you come home Bill
Bailey well especially since you're busy
yeah you're kind of like of all limbs
working and you know right there was one
time in Australia and it's oftentimes
it's just sort of like from my world
it's sort of just like punk rock
wildness things get thrown and things
you know you're playing these smaller
clubs many years many many years ago in
Australia I was playing in Melbourne
Australia and you know people are on top
of your shoulders and there's pits and
they're crowd surfing and all this stuff
is just wild frankly right and so in the
melee of all that a can of beer comes
and I just grab it put it in my mouth
rip it and go and then you're bleeding
like all in one motion
you know and where you kind of don't
realize you're just lost in the moment
thinking like no one hurts me more than
I hurt myself you're out of your mind oh
is that what that was that for me that
was what that was it's like you can't
hit me with you know try to hit me with
something there's no way I do a better
job than you were hurting myself obtain
control of a situation right something
what did the crowd do when you did that
they were like yeah yeah but the look on
everyone's that face of like
as price there's something Priceless to
that too it's like these moments of
wild extremes and oftentimes up there I
don't know uh it's gonna what I'm gonna
do what happened you're in the Green
Room the adrenaline's worn off yeah and
now you got these slices and you're
going hey you're putting yeah and then
you go to the airport and that they you
know the people in customs look at you
like like you're shooting up like
absolutely we we had a light show on our
last tour of the villains tour that were
these like you know tube lights that are
about this tall was on Springs
you know so you could let it go and go
boy and it was like a forest of them and
it was amazing because I'm a bit of a
massacre so I love the idea that you
know we're kind of launching these
lights at each other it's almost it's
dangerous yeah then did you bleed again
yeah it's like so do you have to bleed
every tour probably a little bit a
little uh probably I'm trying to I think
I saw you guys at the Forum last time
you're right and I think that light tree
thing was happening there maybe at that
time
I don't think any there was nobody
through anything it was a la crowd you
know what I mean they were they were in
the uh in the business so let's I know
you want to promote nothing here but
what about uh
is you have a second leg coming up is it
Europe is it we're really just we're
really just starting we did okay we did
Europe and kind of uh initial Festival
run but the United States is starting
right
now you know on two uh Tuesday oh wow
and you know it's just uh I'm actually
you know after
you know I know everybody went through
something the last four years and and I
certainly did too but it's funny that
um
it's created this beautiful appreciation
for what for what it is I get to do
because I'm really looking forward to it
and you know I've had just gonna be
there was going to be some good shows
yeah where you really really yeah I
Really Wanna Go Play I'm I kind of can't
wait I feel like open the gate turn them
loose you know so when you I always ask
people this I just had a buddy ask him
because he's going to go open for a band
and he was sitting there going like two
suitcases one big one one small one is
that too much and I was like yes it's
better to do laundry than carry Dirty
Laundry yeah one pair of pants
two show shirts and then you just have
your travel outfit
and that's that's it that's it I feel
see I've I've you know so what are you
now you dress up though you I remember
when you guys were back in Iggy you guys
had those [__] sick ass well that
because I want to kind of do that hail
Hill Rock and Roll thing where Keith was
backing up Chuck Berry where it's like
we're his gang and we're the band and
then you're different you're in
something else you know because that
just felt appropriate to right to be
like where your boys like
we got you you know there's something
cool and romantic about all that [__] I
just love all that [__] so when you how
much do you bring are you with deep I
don't no I don't bring very much you
know because because I'd rather just do
laundry than carry it yeah and plus
there's something about I don't want to
stand waiting for the [__] bag
everywhere you go uh no I don't check in
anything no I refuse to check in
anything plus I do like to be in a
laundromat there's something really uh
just grounding about doing laundry at a
coin op when you're on tour
you know there's something that's just
like I'm sure you're with you [__]
Cuts all down your arm
reading the local paper yeah like the
the you know the the uh the Washington
DC Gazette right you know there's a yard
sale around the corner that is one of my
favorite things so if I have a day off
in the road before I leave if I get all
of my dirty laundry done yeah it feels
good no dirty laundry in the bag it's
fine you come home you just unpack and
tuck it away yeah it's fantastic yeah
you're like I you know I really did
something I really do I I there's that
feeling of accomplishment about me doing
I also on the second I come home I
unpack yeah come home I say hello
everybody I go upstairs I [__] unpack
everything and I put the uh the suitcase
away or whatever and uh I don't always
make it to that I always do that and
Mia's always just like how do you do
that how do you do that because I go
because that's a little Travis right now
it's a little Travis Bickle just like
talking to me no if I don't do this
right now that [__] thing is gonna
sit there for six weeks yeah it's one of
those things yeah I kind of know and
then it becomes there's something
depressing and you're laying in bed and
about having elements still there on the
back still there exact suitcase but I
always know I'm about to go again I
would struggle with that sort of
relationship with that but I uh
what I noticed though is the so I just
went I once saw uh I went Sun Neil
Brennan the other day he was something
evil theater and I went backstage and he
had
a bag of chips and one water and that
was it
and I was like smart man
I would but and your but your backstage
wasn't a lot of stuff either no because
what happens our backstage is a [__]
Cavalcade of and you're getting ripped
off every night yeah of course because
they're over they're over charging you
of course buying way too much and then
the whoever runs that house goes home
and I'm like what is that that 97 cacao
that's amazing 97 was there 15 of those
like I'm I'm just like mesmerized by it
all the time it's so raw carrots we can
make a juice
you know I'm like I need to take a cue
from what you guys are from no somebody
told me that he said don't have a big
Rider backstage because it's just
another way that they're going to rip
you off because they're going to charge
you all this extra money and uh you know
you're not gonna drink the whole bottle
of booze by yourself so they're just
gonna take it but we always have people
come back and it's like six bottles of
kills out enough is that gonna be enough
for Tuesday is that enough because all
these people come back and it's like I'm
just basically you know try the cacao
but that that's like a that's a band
thing like there's this pressure to have
well it is you know you are turning
Tuesdays into Saturdays when you play I
know and people are taking their
hard-earned money and they're like I got
I Hot Tar roofs and I don't want to do
that I wanted some rock and roll and I
want to cut this you know and I do you
ever hear how AC DC did one tour
AC DC literally part of their set was
backstage they had their own Pub because
they couldn't go anywhere right every
night they would build literally the bar
a place to play darts and they would
feel like they were in a bob table and
it was the same bar every night so it
became like your spot you had your seat
or whatever and you'd go in there and
you could just get a beer and and party
with the crew that sounded to me like
that's [__] perfect well and there is
a bit of blowing off steam you'd think
after you played didn't you just blow
off steam but there's that adrenaline
that's still going like you couldn't
play a show and say I'm tired I'm gonna
go to bed there's no way you know it's
like pick up hockey at 11 30. yeah
it is it's two in the morning it's just
like after afterwards is that what that
I'm I'm totally joking okay I don't
think pickup hockey is the same as being
a rock band playing the [__] I don't
know I've never picked up and it played
any pickup hockey I always would have
liked I think I would have enjoyed
playing I would have been a psycho you
would have been a defenseman and you
would have been the guy that [__]
kept everybody like oh Josh is on the
ice I think I would have enjoyed it yeah
you have our guitar player Dean you know
you know Dean he he plays hockey and
he's kind of got a Travis pickle thing
in him too you wouldn't know to look at
him but he's
yeah this like anything like from
[__]
the pinewood derby when your kids in Cub
Scouts remember that and all those that
then I've said that I'm supposed to
believe a [__] six-year-old built
that yeah oh but what is it with all
that parents are just building their
kids [__] for them it's like that's a
log cab look at the this volcano was
insane well you're allowed to help and
stuff like that I just remember there
was of course they're allowed to help
but for God's sake this is like a
Vesuvius it looks incredible this guy
took a block of wood when my brother was
racing them right because I never joined
the scouts because I saw like it was the
70s my brother would go down to the bus
stop with the Cub Scout thing on and he
would just you know have to fight
um because it was all part of like you
know what do you have you know you Pro
Vietnam War there was just something
about everything was about like not
being with you know any sort of
government even in the scouts yeah so um
they give you like a block of wood and
this guy some I still remember he made a
caterpillar it went up like this it went
down so you must have had like shaved
away he had a band saw and was like he's
slicing an apple and then wood glue and
but the thing about it is the kid's
supposed to be helping it too like
helping too so I mean the guy didn't win
it was not symbolism of being a
caterpillar and growing and getting in
the chrysalis
is just Priceless it was I should have
viewed it that way instead of looking
like I just remember even as a little
kid and I was two years younger than my
older brother going like there's no
[__] way yeah but I deal with that
all the time I go and I look at this
thing you know my kids made something on
their own and a little bit of help but
then I look over and it's like as a
remote control how's the volcano of a
goddamn
[__] remote control was that goo
coming out of this like official goo
and and in that right there what's the
lesson there you see why the world isn't
gonna work
because there's always that guy and that
guy is always rewarded and that guy
ascends good job Tim sends the ladder of
power because he doesn't give a [__]
hey you gotta fake it till you make it
hey any point in the storm yeah you do
what you got to do all of those don't
that all of that [__] is basically I
don't want to do the work I'm not
talented enough but I'm gonna figure out
a [__] way to get there if you don't
make it or you're just faking it forever
I guess
that's a lot of things
yeah yeah there's a lot of people doing
that you know there's a lot of you know
shiny clothes yeah going back to a
one-bedroom apartment
that has not been mine I'm I'm very
conservative
look at me I've always a long time ago I
realized that Malcolm Young was was the
fashion icon [__] love Malcolm yeah
and he never looks bad Dills guys early
on and they were all trying to be a
little bit dazzled then they were like
you know what maybe just Angus but I
love all those early watching all their
early videos like jailbreak and all that
stuff that's the best [__] I mean AC
DC's gotta be in my top one and a half
favorite bands I know of all time
because it's Bon Scott going
like all this sort of like
like uh
like sick royalty and he's such a like
the missing teeth he's older than those
guys yeah yeah did they say I think I
still like he I feel even at 55 he still
when he when he was 34 he still looked
older than me yeah yeah because the hard
living so yeah as proof positive of that
notion when I I went to the experience
Museum in Seattle once on a day off many
many years ago as a traveling ACD
exhibition
and you know there's about 15 of us it
was in the middle of the day on like a
Tuesday type of thing and that's only
like 15 of us and we're all looking at
these uh of different we weren't all
together just 15 kind of people and and
uh and I'm reading this letter behind
glass that Bond Scott has written to his
aunt those like uh have a great time out
of the world doing a lot of coke having
a lot of sex you'd love it out here like
the way the letter to his aunt he wrote
it like that yeah it was like you know
getting [__] up you know yeah doing a
bunch of coke and it's [__] great you
know it's not a groupies according to
doctor the group who's like talking
about groupies and saying you'd [__]
love it out here you know writing to his
aunt I was like this is amazing this is
the best thing I've ever heard and I'm
reading this and I and all of a sudden
on the sort of television screen uh that
I'm sure was on a loop every 15 minutes
it starts to go I don't know
and Thunderstruck starts and everyone in
there just slowly turned around and ends
up by the TV yeah all 15 of us that
don't know each other you know and just
it's a lot it's them live playing it's
[__] incredible I watched the left
every Rock the one from Paris yeah right
before uh Bond passed away yeah
unfortunately and it's just like
the the sheer like force and power yeah
of that band and the the space
well and that you know the Simplicity is
actually hard to do to go down down
that's it yeah just and to be committed
to really sticking it even you know Phil
Rudd not playing too much just going
it's hard to just go and have a real
Groove and I have 80 000 people go nuts
yeah uh well and and even Bon Scott
could sing about rock and roll which is
a hard thing to do too and take
seriously you know you know what it was
about him you just believed what he was
saying because it was because it was 100
real if you if you ever read the letter
yeah
man yeah he's definitely gonna give it a
go I don't think it's gonna work I'm
just saying think about it you know put
it on the scale right but for your life
run for your life you know and and a man
is back in town and it's just like
anybody else is like [__] you you [__]
yeah hear me just like oh [__] Bond's
coming and they're and there he is about
that about that tall but it's still it's
like you believe it because it's
authentic and when I read that letter
that he that he wrote to his aunt I was
like you goddamn right you better lock
that [__] up yeah no it's it's for real
you know my buddy Jesse Hughes he sings
an eagle's death metal he sings about
rock and roll and he he means it too 100
he's like a hundred percent he he owns
like 15 capes do you know anyone else
that has I saw I don't know anyone that
has 15 kids except him and he'll be like
which how does this one what do you
think I'm like yeah that's a that one's
great and they don't come out and he'll
be like this one seems like the call and
I'm like dude just any one of them is
great can we just talk about horsepower
which one yeah but he's like he's like
no but yeah to actually but think about
it which ones and I'm like the blue one
the blue one okay can we get focused on
the task of it but I love that if I feel
like The Odd Couple like crammed it a
Norton it's like
there's a uh I saw him I love that
basement of that uh
I was going to call it a Knights of
Columbus because I'm from Back East but
it's it's for the for the military vets
what do you call those places yeah that
the uh
yeah the legion I saw him in the
basement of that place yeah and you
would have thought he was in front of a
hundred thousand people it was [__]
and he loves the fans like he's he he'll
go to their houses
[Laughter]
he's another guy with a badass
motorcycle I don't know if he still has
that Indian man yeah
gorgeous bike I think he I think he
totaled it and but made it out somehow
alive right it's just like
you know he's the one he's a wild one
you ever see when people like wipe out
and they just get thrown from the car
like there's a amazing car chase of this
guy in a Corvette and he's trying to get
between these two trucks and it's filmed
from overhead in the helicopter and the
thing literally spins right and just
like disintegrates and somehow he just
sort of spits out the side like standing
up like like
in a [__] cartoon and walks away yeah
I had a buddy myself like the drunk
always lives you know and he's because
he's totally relaxed yeah because he's
just going with crash test dummy style
just going with it yes everybody else is
like
clinching down tight you know well that
was there was a comedian that um this
guy Wally Collins was the guy who got me
he goes be careful about driving late at
night because that was the thing like
you check out at two in the afternoon do
the gig and then drive all the way to
the airport and try to drive overnight
and save money on a Motel 6 or whatever
right right so he told me he goes dude
one time he was he was doing that and he
was driving back and he goes
because I was driving and then I just
woke up in a field yeah he was literally
in a field of dreams laying on his back
but I think he could but was he drinking
and driving no he just fell asleep he
was just fell asleep and he just went
with it and I think yeah he was just
totally relaxed and then whatever the
[__] horse was Burrow somebody just
laid him in that [__] field and he
just woke up like what the [__] like am
I dead and uh I should go with it yeah
he told me that story like 25 years ago
and I never
like when I was I would be like nah I'll
throw a big Wally Collins he woke up in
a field [__] this [__] and I would just
I would you know very least pull into a
parking lot well you know when we travel
we're with a big group of it's a full
gang and all these all these people and
tour buses when you tour did you ever do
tours where you just drove a lot so you
did do you drive alone yeah God yeah is
it is that is that a bummer was that a
but just it seems like I was so driving
alone doing like four 20 dates by
yourself and no one else I was not only
walled off I was staring into it like
one day I was like going let me see if I
can go this whole day without talking to
anybody I talked to the person who gives
me the microphone I've done that yeah so
but what I did was and then it started
[__] with me so I started building it
around going to sporting events so I
would just look to see what team was in
town baseball was easy because they have
so many games and they also play in the
afternoon sometimes to sort of just fill
that time and just because I I went out
to Joshua Tree once and was like I want
to see how long I can go without
speaking it was like four days of just
nodding and pointing and you know if you
have to get something
and it started to feel just a little bit
crazy after a while oh it did feel crazy
I mean at first it was kind of rewarding
and and it was just an interesting
to not make any sounds and to not
exchange do anything or speak to anybody
you know and and just go
I'm not gonna lie to those who had dark
ears for me yeah they were very
very seems lonely very dark just like
doing comedy tour driving yourself not
in my college alone was was big in the
midwest out to the The Dakotas and it's
just like
yeah Dakotas like I remember comedy and
The Dakotas I always said like I never
understood like how a band that sounded
as angry as slip knot could come from
Iowa oh I'm like yeah what are we
talking and then you go to Iowa January
or February yeah and you're like oh my
God yeah like this is
you can go nuts out here oh yeah you can
go [__] and if you live away from the
Quad Cities yeah or [__] the Quad
City yeah the Quad City so I think two
of them are in [__] Illinois if
you're not where the action is yeah
especially back then there's action
there now they got good coffee and stuff
everything has just become everything
you know what I mean right there's the
same stuff in the mall there that's over
here but but still when you get on the
sixth story there you know yeah but back
in the day when I was like driving out
to these [__] places like the
colleges you know it was just like but
it's still it's still you know there's
still towns of 300 going on out there in
Iowa make a right on Rural Road H like
they haven't even [__] they haven't
even [__] named it yeah yeah it's
like is this like a [__] reservation
like when am I gonna get Rural Road yeah
what is going on here so those were like
uh
uh Dark Times yeah and a lot of times
the setup wasn't right it's the same
thing like any any part of show business
it's just showing of you probably behind
the chicken wire I would show up like we
don't have a microphone is that going to
be a problem like that type of [__] so
you know there used to be a place called
the uh the Outhouse in Lawrence Kansas
and it was just an empty house uh right
past the county line so the police of
they that was their jurisdiction it was
had no windows and no doors and they
just you'd set up and and because he set
up and and and uh and you know people
would come and they'd charge for shows
and you'd set up your stuff in this
basically in this
empty house you know and the security
where the I mean we I played there when
I was like 18 years old the security was
skinheads and they were all an acid I'm
taking a leak in this corn field and and
I hear and I just hit the deck I dive
into my own urine you know with you know
with joy I guess just to get out and
turn around these skinheads are shooting
these AK-47s of the cornfield and
they're like yeah that's the security of
their own acid it's like
you know you just don't get those
experiences these days oh my God were
they saying [__] they were just oh my
God I have no idea but but you know this
is like sort of that punk rock
underground you're playing these wild
shows and that's some of the stuff that
would happen and in a way
it's well not in a way I love to all
it's not that I love that particularly
because that's not the greatest thing
ever
well but
I but I compare it to sort of the
sterilized versions of stuff that are
today where it's like it's 18 for a beer
and it's not that it needs to go to
skinheads on acid I'm just saying
there's a I miss kind of the wild
subculture everything is so safe now
and maybe it's not the best example but
I don't think that that's even true what
I think what it is is
the corporations took all the mafia's
scams
and but they do it it's legalized so it
feels like
you know like that's a mugging that just
happened there but it's illegal right
and you can just keep figuring out every
like quarter how to make more and more
money and I think that like uh
I think it's an unbelievable like it
it's
sort of sold as this homogenized sort of
yeah man Bed Bath and Beyond but I feel
like it's a really hostile time like
anytime you want customer service it's
[__] Hospital yeah
[__] you well they send you in a little
maze go online you figure it out if you
don't there's nobody to talk to there's
no satisfaction yeah uh type your
question and you might as well just put
a note in a bottle and throw it to the
[__] ocean if somebody's even gonna
get back to you and
um yeah contact at yeah there's no
better business bureau there's nobody
looking out for anybody so uh yeah but I
guess depressing but I guess what I'm
missing is the sort of the the Outhouse
in Lawrence Kansas was when Lawrence
Kansas was people putting on shows
because they were passionate about it
right and yeah the the security at this
on this one night where skinheads on
acid and sure that's not great and it's
a good name for an album yeah
there was a band called Gay bikers on
acid actually a punk rock band from
Texas but uh but at least it was put on
by people that were passionate enough to
put it all together right and uh it was
it was theirs and they were bringing you
out there because they really cared and
um I mean it must have been an event
though it's like [__] amazing nothing
to go it was amazing nothing to compare
to that to end to the and
someone was doing that out of passion
and they've even this empty building and
setting up the generator and doing all
this stuff and it's hard to match that
sort of passion with like
you know
30 parking
28 dollar beer you know what I mean and
like can't go over here can't could you
have that brisp like there's that versus
The Passion of
uh oh yeah there's way more way more
yeah there's control
and that like yeah that was all like
there was there was a whole gorillas
those guys in Boston like they had this
way of sneaking into Boston Garden and
they just went to every game
and to the point they were so bold about
it they actually made a video of
themselves doing it
that they showed on the news they go
look and there they go and there they
are way up there in the catwalk nobody's
like that fall this is a liability I
love that they were still they were so
passionate about about sneaking that's I
love that they're so passionate about
sneaking in but it's just part of their
thing you know it's I said I don't know
why uh that yeah I don't know you
probably just sound like a couple of old
guys but uh when so when you go back on
tour unbelievably relaxed for going out
on tour on Tuesday
I mean because you know things are I'm
I'm just enjoying myself you know I mean
honestly I'm enjoying myself and I I
you know I feel like uh
um I really don't have much to complain
about but I'm looking forward to it and
and how many how many dates how many
dates like how long it's gonna be three
years honestly I've just yes but like
especially because you know uh you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna go slow I I tend to
to overwork myself and and really push
hard and let's go you know I used to
want to do five dates a week and and you
just lose crew they're just like I'm not
you know we're I'm not setting up five
shows a week you know right
um
because I like it when we're kind of
sweaty and dirty and a little bloody and
we're playing great together when we're
like that you know when you're kind of
pushing through the adversity of that
you know
um but I think this time I'm just gonna
go slow and
and enjoy it that's kind of what I'm
doing now yeah I think that's part of
being like you know I'm 55 so now I just
did four weekends in a row yeah that's
great that I was saying to uh my wife
I'm going this is this is young kid [__]
man I can do every other weekend or
whatever but like I
um
yeah
just want to like I feel like to get
here you got to be like for [__] 30
straight years yeah and then it's like
am I gonna and you're supposed to though
right I mean yeah you got to kind of
like [__] you finally get to some
spot where you ask yourself when I I
know I am supposed to stop doing that
and when is that supposed to yeah I am
supposed to at some point enjoy right
and and there's someone on the other end
of this girl ain't two [__] old guys
and it's like yeah yeah oh yeah you're
goddamn right yeah and you don't want to
see me trying to act like I'm [__]
young because that'll be well that's
just kind of gross that's just kind of
it's like uh what was Garth Brooks's
Alter Ego for a second Chris Gaines
Chris where he's sort of like
like you don't want to see an old guy
like try to be like Chris Gaines or
something all of a sudden all right you
know what I mean that's how hard that
guy was crushing it he was just like
makeup that's not anything against Garth
Brooks it's just like some
just I remember that album cover where
it's like
I remember seeing uh some crazy stat
about albums sold in the top five
[__] people and he was in it
like the level that that guy's on the
end you meet on the permanent top 100
list because they take off like the
doors and and you know Michael Jackson
and Dark Side of the Moon you know uh
the Appetite for Destruction Back in
Black Thriller Back in Black yeah
there's some that are just permanently
there they're just there yeah and he had
in the country charts I swear he looks
like like the Tiny Tim
he's not on there
well when are you when are you doing an
LA gig because I want to see you guys
we're about to announce we're about to
announce uh oh but we can't I can't
drive by them because I strike I keep
driving by the Palladium and I keep
seeing your name up on the market
and they're promoting the album oh
really yeah oh oh that's cool oh that's
cool
what like a billboard or some [__] no
it's on the Marquee really it's my
friend thought you were playing that's
what I thought wow look at that I didn't
know that you know I've been really just
you're kind of keeping my head down and
just like
I think that's what been the theme of
this podcast yeah it's not paying
attention
right trying to [__] get into that
bergenstock life
don't ever do that don't ever do that by
the way by the way I I tried some on
today oh really Morgan's like I was just
like a German person I can't do it did
you black sock it too no you know what
it is you know I have ghost white feet
as as white as I am like at least this
is your feet are actually wider whiter
original the original white yeah the out
of the womb white that I was oh I've
never worn them so they were there then
they weren't like burgundy they were
Birkenstock style they were like these
these rubber ones okay so well that's
like so they were like Birkenstocks are
are still better than Crocs which are
like so you're talking about a Croc
level wasn't a Croc it was they were
actually rubber well I guess those are
rubber yeah so you're headed for no I
didn't I didn't want Crocs and my wife
got me some because like because
everybody had kids had him everybody had
now everybody [__]
it's like what are you Mario Batali yes
when you work at the [__] ER
so I got these [__] things and I and
I was wearing them on the beach and I
went into the ocean and they got wet and
then if you leave them out in the sun
they shrink so then I only had like a
[__] week and I'm like what am I
doing with these things they're stupid
it's a that's they're just they're I
just some things can't be done
this pair of Adidas slip-ons yeah those
are [__] those are great those are fine
right yeah proof that's why there's no
reason to go to Croc level for anybody
that's what I kept saying I kept saying
we have Adidas slip-ons it's we're good
I have oh yeah I have a pair of slippers
well just in case and look at that
there's a dragon on mine I've got a
dragon and there's like also there's a
flower there because you can put all
these badges
I had Flair on mine my wife because my
wife knew that I didn't want him so she
flared him up she put some hockey sticks
on them and maybe
they would just give it a chip yeah it
was like the devil the devil horn let's
give it a chance he's cropped Rock just
like you Dad it was really bad uh I like
that she was going the extra mile to try
to sort of Croc you into him it's the
only thing I've ever experienced worse
than my mantis was my bedazzled Crocs
Croc bottom yes well at Croc bottom it's
been an absolute pleasure
I'm so happy for you so happy where you
are in your life with your band and on
this tour and uh I will be looking at
Queens of the Stone Age dot net org
whatever the [__] dot gov dot gov
um to to find out when you're gonna be
out here because yeah I gotta see you
know John Theodore is my guy man oh yeah
he's a monster he's a monster absolutely
monster and I love his [__] playing
on this oh yeah he's playing and live
right now he's playing it like he never
has he's just very
centered and natural and all over it I
mean wait she's got these ludwigs that
sound killer yes that's amazing all
right everybody check out the new album
in times New Rome New Roman I almost set
up Roman all right thank you guys see ya
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's the Monday morning podcast from
Monday August 24th 2015. what's going on
how are you
how's it going
a lovely end of August for all you don't
fret don't fret with the global warming
we'll have summer weather until like
October then we'll have epic [__]
snow storms and then uh then a swarm of
mosquitoes signaling that we're going
winter to Summer's winter to summer
that's how it works now
I don't know why
I don't know if it's because that's the
natural cycle
you know throughout the other throughout
the history of the world the Earth has
gone through cooling off and heating up
parents there's that argument and then
there's the other argument what do you
think too many Q-tips to flush them down
the toilet it is choking all the
mackerel
you know
and we're causing it stop putting hair
spray on your pubes
right
um I have no idea why
all I know is towards the end of the
summer and this is when I get excited
for football and baseball all at the
same time because the games are starting
to [__] matter
um
you know just sucks my team's like 12
and a half [__] games out you know 12
and a half games out but before we get
into any of that [__] let's talk about
the uh the number one controversy in the
[__] country
um my weight loss
no as
as crazy
when they heard that I was quitting
drinking
there was a backlash and um
whatever I quit drinking on July 5th and
I've been trying I was going I was about
a buck 87 a buck 88 and I was going to
get down to those and lose three pounds
a week
over the next uh whatever the [__] that
is whatever that comes out to like eight
weeks or so and I was going to get down
to 162.
and I was gonna have a flat stomach
and I was going to have abs and people
were gonna love me
right
so what happened the first two weeks I
went great
186 down to 183 183 down to 180 right on
schedule then I went to [__] Montreal
and I got my ass kicked I did you know I
went on the road
uh I didn't lose any weight but I didn't
get any weight stayed at a buck 80. so I
was two and one
week three down to Buck uh 77 week four
down to a buck
74 week five down to 171. now this week
all right so I'm five and one
five and one
Oh Billy fat tits turning the bus around
driving away from the bakery
and over to the salad bar
um so this week I needed to be 168.0
to be six and one and have a commanding
lead in the AFC East
of pasty tits right and this week I
weighed in at 168 point
eight
oh Big Time loss oh six and one would
look so good on the calendar now I'm
five and two
I did great up until last night and um
my wife had somebody uh you know in town
that we both knew you know
they're going to do business or whatever
and I knew this person sort of business
and friends so we went out uh went down
to the Rainbow Room
um on Sunset and I had two old duels I
mean that those have to be of all the
empty calories out there
those have to be the emptiest of them
all
and then I had two slices of pizza I did
that around 10 11 o'clock and at my age
that's enough to [__] you over
and um
so whatever so next week I got to be
down to 165 I don't know how the [__]
I'm gonna do that that's almost four
pounds probably not gonna happen I might
have to adjust my goal to 166. in fact I
think I'm gonna we'll just say 166
because that'll be 2.8 pounds right so
rather than me getting discouraged
by not making 165 will be psyched to be
166 and I know what you're thinking like
Jesus Christ Bill that's like when they
give every [__]
dumb kid a goddamn trophy because he he
ran
down the street with his [__] shorts
on right whatever the hell they do in
gym class now
Everybody Clap Your Hands whoever claps
of hands against a [__] trophy I'm
not doing that that way
all right I'm taking the loss I'm five
and two but you got to have realistic
goals here
if I don't hit them then I go oh [__] it
and I go back to boozing
ah and uh nothing too not drinking and
[__] working out makes Billy a tired
boy
drinking I could stay up all night
running my [__] Yap
so anyways 168.8 um
and I'm glad that I'm talking about this
on the podcast because right now I think
I look great
all right
I [__] you know wake up in the
morning look in the mirror and I go God
damn that is one good looking son of a
[__] right I like the way I look right
now
it's been a while so uh the Temptation
is to stop
um do they sing that song Sunshine on a
cloudy day
start hearing that song well I'll get
some chocolate cake right you just start
eating like a [__] [__]
do a little bingo bango as Joe DeRosa
says bingo bango which is a beer and a
shot
um I believe Joe to one of Joe doro's
friends back home coined that phrase
bingo bango and uh there's a few people
doing that last night at the rainbow
room and I was like God damn it that
looks that looks enjoyable
as I look across this sticky table
eating a surprisingly good pizza
surprisingly good slice of pizza for Los
Angeles California at the Rainbow Room
seeing somebody do a little bingo bango
was like oh man
in fact the last time I did that I think
was at the rainbow room I don't go there
often
but when I do
uh you know beer in a shot you got to do
it
why else would you go there
to look at the Nelson memorabilia I
don't think I do
is that his base up on the wall
who knows all right anyways so 168
that's all right so next week I'm going
to go for 166 and then uh
then the following week I'll be what see
that'd be 163 I'll be a pound short so
I'll have to go next a couple of days
and that's what I get that's what I get
for drinking a couple of O'Douls
which I got to tell you for non-alcohol
it's not that bad
it's not good you know what I mean
the emptiest of all empty calories what
a [__] [__] right
so anyways I um
hey by the way my phone is acting up
here I got the [__] iPhone 6. so I'm
supposed to be with all the cool kids
here with all the brand new [__] and for
some reason this thing yeah
I just lost all my [__] text messages
but it's saying I have three
and then it keeps telling me to sign
into iCloud
which I don't want to do and I keep
hitting cancel and then it keeps popping
up again if anybody knows how to make
that go away
make the world go away
um make that [__] thing go away I
would uh
I would really appreciate it
messages what did I do here how come I'm
not getting my messages
so you know what you want to do is uh
click on the settings uh the settings
[__] thingamajiggy there
I have no idea what's going on here I
have the iPhone 6. what happened did I
sweat on it
huh did I drop it in a fish tank
there we say that to you did you drop it
oh yeah I just [__] spiked It On The
Ground pal that's you know you're not
supposed to do that with the phones
yeah I wasn't sure
so anyways um
let's see what do I weigh I weigh 168.8
uh so I'm going for 166 the back of my
head I'm still going for 165.
uh and I'll also I'm gonna ride this
bike that I just got [__] redone
fixed up or whatever a couple times this
week
just because every time I look at it I
hear verzy's voice now going dude you're
never gonna you're never gonna write it
that is the biggest [__] waste of
money
and you know what every time I think
he's right I picture Paul verzi on a
bicycle and I just start dying laughing
and I realize he he doesn't ride a bike
Paul verzi never rode a bike
you know what I mean he likes four-door
sedans anybody likes a four-door sedan
does not like a bicycle
you know the the
what the kind of Motor Trend he's the
kind of guy that he bought a motorcycle
he didn't want to get a [__]
three-wheeler right
am I an [__] here I still realize
you're exposed when you ride those
things but I think the only people who
should ride those are really old bikers
who spent four to five decades riding on
two wheels then they're just too old
you know too brittle
to get back out there in their old horse
so but they still love riding so you get
them to [__] trike
you know you get him the three-wheeler
right seeing these [__] every time I
see a [__] young punk on one of those
things they're always looking over their
shoulder and somebody in like a [__]
German four-door sports car not sports
car a four-door uh sedan is always
chasing them it's happened to me three
times out here I see some kid in one and
he comes roaring up to the red light and
he's frantically looking over his
shoulder and then some kid like a white
BMW was chasing it's like [__] Grand
Theft Auto
actually I only saw it one time but
recently I saw another kid pull up to a
red red light in a three-wheeler and he
[__] looked over his shoulder So
within my head Not only was it happening
again I added another one
almost like Bankers when you deposit a
hundred bucks and then they loan out
that hundred bucks like [__] 90
different to 90 different people
and just counterfeit 800 bucks out of
the [__] air right
um anyways this is the Monday Morning
podcast
um for this week and uh
I gotta uh
I gotta make sure I [__] eat well
this [__] week I gotta do this I
gotta see this thing through I gotta get
down to a buck 62.
um
other than that my [__] Summer's
getting about ready to get [__] great
with football coming around I can't
[__] believe it's almost here you
know I am so jonesing for sports right
now that I actually taped um
if you wonder about my weird breathing I
had a [__] burrito today I'm just I'm
going off the rails but I'm talking
about it out loud here
so I don't [__] up you know what happens
first day look in the mirror you're like
dude I look good I look fine right then
that part of your brain goes hey let's
go to McDonald's
you know what I think I will
um
but I actually watched Serena Williams
in the semi-finals of that uh Cincinnati
tournament
and I didn't see it today I kind of got
into all these obscure tournaments I
only used to watch like the finals of
the majors but right now I'm reading
Andre agassi's book uh open which I
highly [__] recommend especially
for somebody who's trying to accomplish
something or if you [__] hate tennis
the way he describes
what you go through mentally
God I can't stop yawning
what you go through mentally when trying
to win a tournament or just trying to
get better
or not get psyched out because you're
the new kid and you're playing against
John mcenrose or some [__] Legend
um
it's an incredible book so I I started
and what has fascinated me more than the
majors has been all these what I
consider jerk off tournaments that I
never paid attention to Indian Wells
Cincinnati
you know the clay season I I only
thought there was just the French Open
and that's it he was like saying that
there's the clay season the grass season
they got all these other [__] obscure
tournaments and you know what I love
most about them plenty of [__] seats
Jesus Christ you could have just walked
into Cincinnati and sat down and watched
uh whoever the [__] you wanted
tremendous so I watched Serena win
and today she won the whole thing in
Roger Federer also won and I guess he's
looking young
you know looks like he's rewinding the
clock there and uh the U.S opens around
the corner
[Music]
am I making you guys yawn I don't know
what's going on with me
I don't know what's going on here
um you know what it is I ate a bunch of
[__] food my body's reacting to it right
now it's [__] just shutting
everything down
you know like when you close all the
extra apps because it's sucking off your
[__] battery there
you know what I mean I think that's what
my brain's doing right now all right
let's shut it down and deal with this
[__] up thing he just put in our
stomach
this is the priority everything else
like Consciousness doesn't [__]
matter anymore
so anyways um
I'm actually psyched to watch uh to
watch the US Open and actually to watch
Tennis on a level that I never watched
it before which is basically uh to pay
attention to is they
the person keep hitting to the other
person's forehand to their backhand they
hit the right atom where do they put it
in the box when they [__] serve it
you know does the person cheat in I used
to watch that though if they cheated in
you know if they're standing a few feet
behind the Baseline then on the second
serve the inside the Baseline and that
type of shot you know I never used to
pay attention to that [__] but it
actually makes tennis way more enjoyable
to watch and uh so whatever you know I'm
not a big reader but I'm actually
enjoying the uh Andre Agassi booked
there so uh anyways uh Jesus 14 [__]
minutes are just babbling
Babylon so anyways did anybody watch I
was on Conan this week I want to thank
everybody over there once again had a
[__] awesome time how great is Kona
man
that guy just rolls whatever every time
you get out there and as you noticed I
was hyping uh the Madison Square Garden
Show which is uh
obviously a big deal for me and um
oh wait a minute I already talked to him
did I kind of talk about this well I
said who was going to be on it
um
and whatnot whatever that's fun though
that [__] is always fun doing [__]
panel
it's a lot easier than coming out there
and doing [__] stand up you know what
I mean
we just had to go out there and host the
show
going out doing panels easy you just sit
down if you get someone cool like Conan
he just [__] sets you up just tease
you up the whole time you know and then
if you're on a nice run he lets you go
and then if you [__] fall on your
face he uh he jumps and he saves you
right
Tim and Andy
um
so once again thanks to everybody over
there had a [__] awesome time as
always and uh all right oh let's get to
the big [__] thing of this week
that affected my life the big
controversy the big blowback
in this comedy climate that we live in
which obviously what I'm talking about
I've kind of been dancing around it for
the first 14 minutes
because I've been debating about whether
or not to talk about this and just throw
more gas on the fire or just let it burn
itself out of course what I am talking
about is ESPN
retracting their statements and
apologizing to the New England Patriots
at 12 20 in the [__] morning
can you [__]
can you [__] believe that is ESPN not
the biggest bunch of [__] [__]
ever first of all they re-reported a
story that was retracted in 2007 and
it's that classic one that oh some guy
heard a rumor that somebody said that
the Patriots filmed the Rams walk
through
before the Super Bowl that story came
from the Boston Herald it was retracted
in like [__] 2007 according to the
three seconds of [__] research that I
did before I did this podcast ESPN I
evidently recently repeated it I never
watched ESPN anymore
um
um they somebody tweeted it to me that's
how I actually know about this [__]
um
so I guess they they brought it up again
as if it hadn't been retracted and
proven false so then they had egg on
their face and rather than apologizing
during the time of day when they [__]
first reported it they did it quickly at
12 20 in the [__] morning what a
bunch of babies
you know so there you go everybody all
you Patriot haters have you noticed all
the all the paint peeling off your
[__] arguments
how about this how about this
we're the best [__] football team in
the NFL for the last 15 years and we got
the trophies and the Rings to prove it
all right other than that you can get on
your knees and suck a giant [__] dick
with your [__] [__] arguments all
of it from Spygate right to the fleet
gate the filament practices all of it is
a bunch of [__] [__]
Spygate might be the worst one ever if
you ever do any research on it and
Google some of the best coaches in the
league talking about filming other
[__] teams
putting binoculars on them a veritable
who's who of Hall of Fame coaches
talking about doing it so
[__] all you guys and I can't hear you
I can't hear you anymore because I know
you're just gonna have to retract it
soon enough but by all means keep giving
Seattle
you know with their own owner [__] over
his own fan base with the alleged large
beer in small beer building a stadium
that makes his team sound louder than
they actually are and all squeaky clean
[__] Pete Carroll oh yeah there's a
[__] altar boy for you I'm sure
nothing you know what he got busted for
doing something a little gamesmanship
last year having people reporting to
practice before they should have to try
to get some extra advantage that's all
right
that's just because he's so dedicated
they're not cheating out there though
I'm the Raiders the Cowboys there's a
couple of squeaky clean [__]
franchise give me a [__] break [__]
all you guys [__] all you [__] year
[__] all you all right
We are the champions again I love it I
love it ESPN with their tail between
their [__] legs
12 12 20 in the [__] morning oh yeah
by the way uh all that stuff we said
about the pages was [__] anyway
Shameless ESPN who fanned the Flames of
that [__] deflategate after they
[__]
after they did a study and proved that
it was a disadvantage and then they
tried to quickly take it down oh you
[__] horse
go [__] yourselves all right let's do a
little advertising here for this week
all right what do we got here
um speaking of [__] me undies I went
and visited a friend of mine today down
on Manhattan Beach and I have a number
of friends that have recently moved out
there and they keep telling me ah dude
you gotta [__] move out here
it's awesome you know you can walk
around everything's [__] cool first
time I go down there there's this crazy
homeless guy right who will just be
walking around muttering then out of
nowhere he just [__] yelled so loud
and like throw this crazy punch and
every time it scared the [__] out of me
and I knew it was coming he'd be just
walking away
no he just kept going
and you just [__] throw this punch
and every time it made me give me like a
little [__] heart attack like what's
his face in Biloxi blues and uh
so I'm thinking all right it's night
time
you know the beach is just like you know
it's just tree it just attracts so many
[__] losers
you know because their whole deal is
like even if I [__] up I can still
survive and live outside
curl up in the warm sand you know what I
mean
so anyways um I'm walking down there
today with my buddy it's during the day
and it's more like family time and I'm
walking down the [__] street right
and there's like these two [__] girls
I don't know how old they were but they
didn't have any curves yet
and they're wearing these bikinis and
they got like three quarters of their
ass
that they don't even have yet hanging
out of the back of it
and I'm looking at my buddy and I'm
going like dude why are those little
girls like they were like [__] 12.
walking with their asses
what what is what the [__] is wrong with
parents today I want to walk up to
parents and just be like that's okay
with you
do you ever watch To Catch a Predator
what the [__] are you doing
can you put your kids asses away please
[__] worst parent they literally
should somebody should just come up and
just I don't know what
what do you [__] just dump a bucket
of ice water over their parents head and
just scream wake up you know
people if you have young children can
you cover them up
Jesus Christ that was so creepy it
should have been in one of those [__]
uh
who's a guy who does it used to be uh
Calvin Klein had the creepy [__]
[__] kids like locked in the cellar
remember those [__] commercials and
it was like the guy off camera
just being like so what do you like to
do for fun
oh yeah
those jeans are kind of falling off your
hips aren't they
that's [__] awful
that awful commercial my favorite one
ever
Jim the taxi driver
that Donell Logue did you ever see when
he did I can't find it but he did a
parody of that and he was sitting there
with like his his pants half pulled down
answering the questions of some creepy
guy off oh it's [__] hilarious but
then the latest American Apparel
you know that creepy [__] feeling you
get if you're any sort of a human being
when you look at an American Apparel ad
you know I actually tweeted about it one
time
you're like you're pulling up to it and
you know old man you're [__] pulling
up with your bad eyes going Jesus look
at the ass on that
12 right that's the same thing that's
the same [__] feeling
today it's like what the f why
who's the [__] creep that makes a
bathing suit for a little girl like that
you know
I don't know
whoever it is he he go he Co he goes by
Uncle
that's always a [__] that's always a
dead giveaway when somebody's in their
40s they're not married
right and they're still hanging out with
people half their age and they go oh
just call me [__] uncle whatever
that's when you immediately have to
leave and and if there's any drink in
the room don't drink it right my [__]
nuts
that's just what I believe
all right so I mean I who am I I don't
have any [__] kids I shouldn't say it
but for the love of God you know if your
kid's like you know
if you add your kids age
foreign
it's like
under five you know one plus two three
you know what I'm saying that probably
the math and I shouldn't use a math
equation I'm too [__] dumb for that
I'm just saying you know what the [__]
I'm saying and then it makes you feel
like a [__] creep
it's like would you get that out of here
please
horrific horrific parenting
um
all right let's let's plow ahead here
the [__] else was I going to talk about
I think that's that's it
is that all I have to I apologize lately
these [__] podcasts I have absolutely
nothing to talk about because I've just
been in a [__] edit room
um oh I can't tell you this uh the drum
lessons have been going [__] great
trying to get that molar method thing
down finally after all these goddamn
years let's see if I can actually uh
sign in at iCloud sign in at the [__]
iCloud
what the [__] is this thing now I can't
even look at my photos
yeah Jesus does anybody know what's
what's what is better than the iPhone or
what's comparable to it
so anyways right now I'm going through
that book The Art of Bob drumming by
John Reilly I'm just [__] with two
two lines on one page and it's blowing
my mind all the different ways you can
play it so uh
I've got to have fun for the rest of the
year here anyways you know what you're
supposed to get no why don't I just
[__] get to the goddamn questions
and I'll [__] go from there
um somebody sent me this thing teens
react to encyclopedias you know because
they all grew up on computers and [__]
and they're looking at them like what
the [__] are these and uh I really
wanted to laugh at them that they didn't
understand or thought encyclopedias were
stupid but they it
seconds into it as I was just like this
is what I sound like
when I'm trying to use an iPhone or any
sort of computer
so I can't make fun of them right
that wouldn't be fair and to be honest
with you I understood encyclopedias and
I sucked at those too
that was a big deal though if you were
any sort of a [__] nerd man and you
got encyclopedias then they came out
with more specific ones like ones that
were just dedicated to sports I would
[__] read those all goddamn day
all goddamn day and like you know my
parents and everybody would get them get
mad like what are you gonna get out of
that [__] what are you gonna get out of
that
it's like I don't know
maybe someday there'll be a 24-hour
Sports Network that I could get a job
and make millions of dollars a year
and say things that aren't true and then
retracted at one in the morning
deported Coke habit and get some [__]
I mean who knows there's all kinds of
[__] that could happen here
um
but watching that just took me back to
those days of having to do [__] book
reports and all of that oh my God book
report
you know he's just waiting to do it
there was always that [__] kid that
just had the [__] ability to just go
home read the book and get it done
and just get on with their life
I would just sit there staring at the
book walking by it every day like it was
like uh
I don't know Medusa's head like I was
going to turn to Stone if I [__]
looked at the thing I really wish I you
know if I could go back and do my life
over again there's just so much [__]
that I just would have faced immediately
and just gotten it over with
from [__] ass kickings to book
reports
to uh
the Mueller method playing drums just
sitting down and dedicating [__]
three months of my life to get a little
bit of muscle memory so then it slides
in eventually to my playing
and just say okay the next three months
are gonna [__] suck whether it's
going to be slow increments of growth
when I come out the other side I'm going
to be really excited I just wish I had
that when I was a kid and it's something
that I've slowly developed
as I've gotten older especially once you
get out of school and you actually get
to start choosing things that you want
to do as opposed to having to do
um
you know get my helicopter license and
[__] like that um
you know back in the day that would have
just ate me up I would have saw all his
assignments and be like I have to
remember [__] [__] this man and I would
just try to make people laugh in the
[__] class and then that would be it
next thing I was in summer school with a
pouty look on my face like I wasn't
there because of me like somehow I had
been [__] wrong so
anyways I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about here but if you can
develop that
you know on any [__] level it makes
your day so much less stressful you ever
just make a list of [__] you have to get
done and you wake up and you just do it
and then you look and it's like [__]
11 30 in the morning you got the whole
rest of your day
you know that's a great way to spend
your day and it's also a great way to
actually develop a drinking problem
because then you got the whole [__]
day
you got no responsibility
might as well get [__] faced right
speaking of boozing
um I do and I don't I miss it at night I
don't
or when I step on the scale I don't miss
it but I have to tell you this
um
and you can call me a snob
my wife is totally into that American
Greed
and uh one of the things that I find
these guys constantly spending money on
we're just blowing money on is doing
like thousand dollar shots of cognac
cognac however the [__] you say it and
um me and Jason lawhead
did a hundred dollar shots one time
one time we said [__] it we both did a
show you know I had sold some posters he
sold some [__] CDs and we had some
merch money and we were just like [__]
it
let's just take the much money let's
blow it on one shot let's [__] taste
this [__] and it was unbelievable
and um
you know unlike whiskeys that seem to
only go up to about I don't know 20 25
years like Bourbons like those cognacs
can go I mean as far as I know I saw
some on the internet because I was
looking them up that went back hundreds
of years is that true I know wine can go
back like that but uh
I was wondering anybody out there
currently embezzling money from a
company and can recommend
you know obviously I'm not going to do a
thousand dollar shot
but can you recommend
some uh
you know dipping my toe in the water
when I come off the sink because as
you're hearing this I'm 50 days in to my
72-day uh
stay of uh no [__] alcohol I'm
already 50 days in huh a little quick it
goes
um
so when I come out of it man I would
really love to uh
I would really love to um
try something like that
because with that [__] you're just
sitting there like
I remember when they poured the shot I
was almost afraid I was gonna spill it
I forget how it was like 60 years old
I'm like oh my God this is like
I forget how old I was at the time I was
like this this is like 15 years older
than me
like this thing was put
into the barrel whatever they do when
like Harry Truman was still in the uh
like he was just well I can't no wait
Trump early was Truman in early 50s I
think yeah the early 50s I think Truman
was in office right
um well let's see he finished World War
II
dropped the bomb that was like 46.
19. Jesus Christ build the [__]
internet's right in front of you
can you stop torturing the goddamn
listeners who the [__] was president in
1952. I'm going with Truman I thought it
went FDR Truman and then Eisenhower
uh
um
U.S
presidents
1952 and it is Harry S Truman go [__]
yourself bam
that guy looks like somebody I wouldn't
[__] with man there's just something
about those round Rim glasses you know
what he looks like he looks like the
actor that played the warden in the
[__] Shawshank Redemption doesn't he
I wonder if he called up Japan after he
dropped the second one do you like that
second one or am I being obtuse
um anyways
what the [__] am I talking about what am
I talking about oh I'm talking about the
cognac
um I was almost afraid to [__] spill
it and then also you didn't want to
drink it really fast you wanted to like
savor it
so I'm thinking when I go back to
boozing
so I'm not bingo bango in the whole
[__] time I'm actually just sipping
it nice and slow like nice and slow say
that's the way to do it nice and slow
um so
um for those of you who are my age and
that you were like where the [__] is
that from where the [__] is that from I
don't want to torture you that was the
from the Fred Flintstone episode
when Fred got mugged
and the guy was telling the reach in to
grab his stegosaurus wallet right and he
was going nice and slow she
dashed away to do it nice and slow
remember the guns like the barrel was
made out of us like a hollowed out tree
branch and then you just with I don't
know the tendon of a bird you stretch
back to [__] rock I guess that would
kill you back then I had no idea did you
know that caveman's had pistols I love
the [__] caveman diet by the way
everybody it's a caveman diet
this is what caveman ate yeah yeah they
probably ate worms and they ate ants
they probably ate anything that they
could [__] get their goddamn hands on
the Dirty Filthy Hands and then they
died of some intestinal virus when they
were like 15.
you know I let the caveman die like who
the [__] knows what they ate
do they draw a picture of it on the
inside of a cave how the [__] do you
know what that is
they should call that our guess
of the caveman diet
all right well let's see we know Fritos
weren't around back then crossed those
off the list
like do you honestly think that there
was like
like where the [__] was cantaloupe
where was an avocado where the [__] was
any of that [__] you're just walking
around
trying not to get eaten
you grab a stick you stab some I would
think that you're eating [__]
Roadkill
yeah hunting [__] and then you're just
eating stuff you stick and you slam in
your face in a stream
right
trying to be up River of somebody else
who's down there with his [__]
prehistoric goddamn balls and taint in
the [__] water
I don't know who knows what the [__]
they I'm so sick of people telling me
about the goddamn Caveman Diet that's a
caveman diet
I have an egg over easy
um all right let's get on with the uh
let's go with the questions here for
this week uh lady fan lady
hey ladies hey there Bill I'm a lady fan
and I'm exciting excited what and am
seeing you for the first time in Chicago
in October so excited see what my brain
does it's it's reading one sentence
while it's looking at words in the next
line below
I don't want my [__] problems here my
husband has been acting weird about us
coming to see your show I think it's
because a few weeks ago we were watching
one of your specials and I said you were
my celebrity crush oh Jesus my husband
chose Scarlett Johansson nice
I like this guy of course I would never
cheat on my husband but I'm afraid if I
enjoy your show too much he's going to
give me a side eye look or bring it up
later can you please put his mind at
ease
um
why do I have to put his mind at ease
why don't you quit picking people that
are attainable
[Laughter]
he went Scarlett Johansson there's
nowhere there's no way he's gonna get
anywhere near her
you pick some [__] dope that tells
dick jokes in a strip mall no wonder
he's looking at you [__] up
how dare you make a [__] mess and
then tell me to mop it up
what is in it for me
um
yeah what are we talking about you know
I'm not I don't put him at ease
what are you gonna do run up on the
stage I'm gonna do the show and then I'm
fine I'll be out the I'll be out the
[__] door because I'm drinking
baby I'm drinking again
right
I don't know you shouldn't have said
that
like look if my wife if I asked her what
is her celebrity crush and she says Brad
Pitt she says [__] Denzel I don't
give a [__]
she might as well be picking a man on
the moon
right
but if she named like a [__] comedian
that performs at The Comedy Store like I
do yeah I would be like well what the
[__]
you could you could bang that person
while I was on stage the next time I'm
at the store yeah
so that's on you sweetheart what you
should say is I didn't oh did I say Bill
Burr I meant Raymond Burr yes the dead
fat guy
yeah that guy that's that's what I'm so
why was I saying
why was I saying or Billy Bush that's
what I meant
hi I'm Billy Lush
um all right
she closed the thing with uh you know I
just want to have a good time at your
show without worrying about him being
weird you created the weirdness
um all right
okay being a landlord from a lady this
is two two letters from A Lady this is a
[__] uh this is a record here dear
Billy butter cheeks uh you've been
talking about becoming a landlord lately
so I thought I'd write to you about what
it's like to be one please don't step on
my dream
okay before I even read this I know that
if it's as big a nightmare as everybody
claims it would be no one would be a
[__] landlord
all right all right first know that your
property will be destroyed
you need to prepare yourself to watch it
get trashed over and over again because
your tenants either by negligence by
ignorance
parentheses not letting you know when
something's wrong until it's very very
wrong or in spite when they vacate the
feeling of seeing your property ruined
over and over again sucks and it's
expensive
second someday you will have to evict
somebody that sounds easy but it's not
especially for anybody with a heart and
I know you have a big heart you can't
hide it from me I'm from Ohio
uh the first time someone burst into
tears upon being served in eviction
notice and Spins their sob story well
you might not believe them you might go
ahead in a victim but you will forever
wonder if you did the right thing and if
it's an elderly person or a disabled
veteran forget it how can you do that
you can't
um yeah there's no way I could do that I
own properties in Seattle and Portland
and with all the Californians fleeing
the drought they were only
wait wait
wait they were only going to appreciate
in value but climate change refugees are
going to be desperate people and I
didn't want to take advantage of their
plight I didn't want to become that
person someone will no doubt but it
won't be me I don't have the heart so
think about it twice
sure it seems like easy money and
sociopaths will tell you it's no sweat
with a good lawyer but you have to be
very detached emotionally I wasn't
capable of that so I sold out there are
so many other ways to invest your money
just my two cents I'm a lady so feel
free to toss in this to toss this in the
trash come on go [__] yourself
uh all right
um
all right well it seems like you didn't
have the hearts you got out of it uh
yeah that would hurt me if people [__]
it up
um whenever I [__] up I had a dog I
have a dog and she [__] it all up and
before I left I got everything fixed and
they were really surprised
um because when I went to move out they
were like going yeah uh but before we
move out we need to inspect that damage
because somebody came over and fixed the
sink saw all the the damage like the
wood moldings and that type of [__] in
one of the windows
uh for my dog with its separating
separation anxiety tore it all up but I
had it all fixed before I left
out of respect and then also knowing
that landlords will go down to Home
Depot
and spend 20 bucks and then charge me my
entire [__] deposit
so uh I eliminated that from the
equation I'm still going to become a
landlord I think it's a great [__]
investment and I do have the heart to uh
give people a break and I also think I
know when someone's bullshitting me
um
yeah you know what I mean pay you
[__] rent or beat it you got to get
in that mindset you know what I think it
is I think people who really are
landlords and don't give a [__] and look
at [__] is bricks and bricks and mortar
in a black and white probably do the
best in that business
and uh so I think you got to do that you
know what I mean you got to watch the
movie Heap and listen to De Niro talk
about how you got to be willing to walk
away at any second you know you got to
be willing to evict somebody and just
[__] walk away
all right bill
okay thank you for doing the podcast
easy for people to take that you could
be a little more reliable uploading
Thursdays though
what a [__]
um
all right here we go I actually [__]
up that guy's joke he was trying to act
like he was going to be cool here thank
you for doing the podcast easy for
people to take for granted slash bust
your balls on Twitter but know that they
are appreciated uh the podcasts are
appreciated uh you could be a little
more reliable uploading Thursdays though
still being a [__] all right I've been
steadily losing my hair for the last
couple of years it's getting to the
point where I'm thinking each haircut
might be the last before I start buzzing
it all kind of crossing my fingers that
there's still a comprehensive head of
hair when the barber Springs the chair
around I've come as close as I can to
making peace with the life of baldness
not thrilled about being here at 30 and
women slash guys with with hair
don't really get what a bummer it can be
but what are you going to do my question
how do I talk about this with my wife we
have discussed it
what we haven't discussed it whatsoever
as she is able to sense my discomfort
with the topic and has never tried to
force the dialogue my wife and I have an
honest relationship and have openly
discussed topics much more Awkward with
actual real world ramifications
all right so you've talked about having
a threesome
ah [__] all right it's also not like she
can't see the hairlines going but I've
built up a whole awkward wall around the
topic and I'm not sure how to slice
through it
did you have any conversations with Nia
prior to hacking off what was left of
your hair any words of wisdom from the
post Buzz world
uh hoping to catch you at a future Steve
Allen theater slash Comedy Store gig
best of luck at Madison Square Garden
thank you very much
uh yeah it was actually Mia's idea
because I kind of wanted to do it
and uh she was like you should do it you
should do it it's like oh man you know
because the big thing is what kind of
head do I have
because you don't have that flat [__]
thing in the back you know what I mean
well the back of your head goes straight
into your [__] neck
um so I started saying that I was gonna
do it
and she just kept [__] singing this
song
um Nia
I'm gonna bring her in here
she kept saying she'd go shave your head
shave shave your head come on now every
time I would walk by and then she just
yell shave it just do it [__] shave
it hold on a sec see if I can get her in
here
Mia
I got it I gotta I gotta bring this uh
I gotta bring this one back
this guy right he's losing his hair he's
like 30 years old all right he's almost
to the point where he's gonna he's gonna
shave his head
and he was saying because I did it you
know what I mean he doesn't see but he
doesn't talk about it with his wife
and she knows that he's sensitive so
he's built like this awkward wall but
it's just totally obvious and they were
saying did you ever have a conversation
with Nia about shaving my head and as
far as I remember it was your idea right
it was you remember that song you used
to sing
remember that and I would laugh
about that yeah and then I finally went
ahead and did it I will tell you this
the first time how long come here come
over here when was it that you've Did It
For the First Time how long ago get on
the mic here
um about nine years ago it's the first
time I did and then when I did date
night they asked me to grow it back and
I was like and I was like I was like
going well there's not much to grow back
and they were like yeah we'll fill it in
we'll fill it in or whatever so I was
like all right and then I grew it back
and then I kept it for a while because I
started thinking like this is why I'm
getting uh acting roles which is the
dumbest thing you can do it's not
because of my skills it's because of my
hair yeah it's a balding which was
stupid and
um I would say it's the greatest [__]
thing if you're it's the greatest
[__] thing you'll ever do and I'm
actually reading Andre agassi's book
where he was talking about I didn't know
he wore a [__] hair piece and one
time he was in the shower before the
French Open final and he was in the
shower and his whole hair piece came
apart so they had to [__] glue the
thing back together so he went on the
court and played this guy he could have
beaten the whole time he was worried
that his [__] hair piece was going to
come flying off like a Three Stooges
episode you know [__] embarrassing
that would have been that would have
been terrible yeah he talks about how
uh I guess Brooke Shields finally
convinced him to do it and he did it and
then he felt great yeah I will tell you
it's it's the greatest fight it's the
greatest thing ever the greatest [__]
thing
you could all these [__] guys going
out and and like [__] slicing up the
back of their heads or having this [__]
vacuumed out and then parrot trooped on
top of their head
like most of that [__] it works for a
minute
and but then the thing is is like those
they go the hairs in the back of your
head
don't
um those things never fall out so if you
put them on the top of your head then
you're okay but the thing is you still
have all that other hair up there that's
gonna fall out so that [__] falls out
and then you need more [__]
Replacements and then sometimes you can
actually it can like not work as far as
I know so
I'm a big [__] uh I don't know I'm a
big just I think it's a [__] way
better move
I actually think it's the man move
you're [__] dealing with the hand
you've been dealt you just do it this is
what I look like people go what the [__]
for a few days and then they think you
look when they see pictures of you with
hair they think you look weird and then
you're free
you're [__] free so rather than going
there to the barber every time and
putting your head down as he cuts it and
then open your eyes going what does it
look like now just [__] get it over
with get it over with dude shave your
[__] head what are you say Nene Janet
yeah shave it it's [__] awesome then
you love it you know what's great no
matter how late you wake up for work you
can just throw on clothes and get there
no one will know you didn't take a
shower because you don't have Bed Head
anymore
bye Nene bye all right
hey should oh I'm not gonna talk where
me and you are actually considering uh
doing a project together
might write a book but it's not the kind
of book you think it's not about us
um so is that dumb is that dumb to get
in a business why why would it be you
know me
why not you know I ever get divorced or
take me for half I got so I might she
might as well [__] be helping me
create you know
you can tell she's not in the room
anymore all right let's let's read
let's read the last of the advertising
by the way if you guys are going to go
to a comedy club out here you got to go
down to The Comedy Store man they got a
line around the block
and I think I know why listen to this
[__] lineup I was on
I went on on the main room Friday night
and I walked in Mark Maron was on stage
who then brought up David Spade who then
brought up Joe Rogan and then I had to
go on after all of those [__]
monsters
um
it's unbelievable dude The Comedy Store
lately it's it's get your ass down there
everybody's been [__] coming through
and um
just insane insane [__] shows down
there it's fun you know when Rogan has
been working out like a maniac on his
[__] act he was destroying in front
of me
you know it's funny as as a comic that's
been doing it this long you know I
always watch Rogan but I was talking to
somebody but like subconsciously you're
hearing the laughs and at one point he
was getting this level of laughter that
I had to end the conversation and then
start making a set list I'm like I just
can't just walk on the stage after this
[__]
Mayhem that's going on out there I
actually I need a game plan here
um
which is another [__] great reason to
go down there you know what I mean all
those guys pushing you
um all right let's get let's read the
last couple here all right bullied at
work
hi Billy buff boy uh I work in an office
with several young females so several
young ladies
um sounds good right wrong
I'm the only young male here
so what's wrong they like to gang
he said gain g-a-i-n gain up on me it's
gang g-a-n-g
Ang up on me and constantly put me down
or make fun of me it started out all fun
and games but some of them have recently
become very aggressive and are almost
verbally attacking me
what what I don't understand what is the
problem here when I brought it up to
them it just made it worse and made me
more of a Target yeah dude you never got
bullied before
the last thing you say to a bully is hey
what you're doing is really bothering me
just so you know
uh
um what can I do to make this situation
better without getting management
involved I don't want to get them fired
or anything I just want
I just don't want to be the female
punching bag anymore thanks
I don't understand what is going on here
what are they saying to you
if they're giving you [__] you got to
give them [__] back
you know what I mean come on man
defeating a [__] woman in a verbal
thing you know where you have to go but
you can't go there because then they're
gonna rat you out to the boss
this is what you do just walk in right
just walk in with your eyes squinting
one day
you know looking like an idiot just walk
in just in blinking a lot just squinting
and walk right up to the one with the
smallest chest
[Music]
[Laughter]
and don't do that I was just gonna say
just do that and she goes what are you
doing just go I'm trying to see your
titties
it's so childish
but unbelievably effective
and I think I mean I'm not going to
speak for women here but what I really
think it is is women realize the
unbelievable power that they have over
guys with their looks
so if you ever indicate that there is a
flaw in their looks or that they're
starting to slip it really [__] with
them it's too mean I dude I don't have
[__] sympathy for you what are they
just verbally abusing you give them [__]
back
Kevin what are they saying we're right
back to me
right back to me what the [__] are you
one of those kids did you always wear a
helmet when you rode a bicycle
did you have play dates are you part of
that [__] generation dude come on man
snap out of it
yeah that just I would just be like hey
what are you [__] gonna stop being such
[__] something you gotta you gotta
shoot something across the bow
you got to give him [__] dude
you got to give him [__]
just point it whatever they're wearing
be like oh my God where did you get that
and then just keep walking that's all
you have to do that [__] up a woman's
day
what do you mean by that dude I think
that huh you just give it back to him
just give it back to him dude I I don't
you [__] grow a dick and give it back
to a man come on
this is this is like this whole [__]
thing I'm guessing you're a younger
person oh you said a young male yeah
you've been completely beaten down
to the point where you're now you know
we went from men beating women with
[__] mop handles a hundred [__]
years ago to now this this to the point
of a complete over correction that
you're gonna sit here and allow yourself
to get verbally abused
because they're women I do like the fact
that you don't want to be a rat and rat
them out this is what you got to do okay
treat them with the same level of
respect they're treating you uh I would
avoid name calling and I would
definitely not curse but other than that
I would be just as [__] mean as they
are
I just do they're so easy to [__] with
the next time one of them says something
to you just offer some gum
and just keep doing and just being like
listen I'm not trying to be a jerk I
don't know what you've been eating late
but I've noticed it over the last few
days and just invent in their head that
they have this [__] halitosis that's
that's it and then you divide and
conquer it's a joke dude it's not that
[__] hard
you know what I mean just tell them
which one you think is the most
attractive and why and let the other two
losers [__] deal with that and the
other one will actually feel good that
you said it about her so now she's not
[__] with you and then the other two
are pissed at the other girl and then
you get some infighting
and don't bring it down to looks just
say you know just you gotta she has a
certain level of class that the other
two of you lack I'm not trying to be a
jerking just [__] leave it nice and
vague like that that's all you do and
all I'm doing is taking a page out of
their book because women are Masters at
that vague mind [__] and then walking
away it's a work of art I don't even
think they have to work at it are they
just born with it
tremendous
it probably goes back in the day from
when they were dragged around from cave
to Cave by their [__] hair they had
to say something that mind [__] the
hairy douchebag
that was about ready to take advantage
of them so they could walk away before
he [__] dragged him into the cave
oh Jesus Christ I'm just [__] talking
all kinds of [__] here all right let's
wrap this thing up here career advice
dear
Alexia Burr
oh that's a great one and accurate I've
been a high school teacher for the past
seven years
but my dream has always to become a
professional writer
oh that's awesome
you know dude that would be a great life
you molded some young minds and then you
became a professional writer so far he
says so far I don't have a teaching job
for the upcoming school year I'm
considering no longer having my own
classes and instead becoming substitute
teacher for the school year this would
give me more time to write and submit my
work to literary agents and hopefully
get a big publishing deal I've had some
success so far with writing a published
short story and a nomination for a
literary prize dude what the [__] are
you waiting for
how many more signs of land do you need
this is like Columbus when he [__]
sailed over and he saw some tree
branches and a couple of birds
you're going to get there the problem is
that my wife and I still have a lot of
student debt that we're repaying and
substitute teaching does teaching
doesn't pay nearly as much as being a
regular classroom teacher I put off my
dream of becoming a writer for years and
I think now maybe the time to
metaphorically push in all my chips I
might lose but I might win no dude
there's no way there's no way you lose
when you go after a dream
you don't it always leads to something
better always
all right
dude [__] substitute teacher teach
and be a [__] Uber driver
all right and you know
eat at home more starving artist I slept
on a futon until I was 36 I don't
[__] regret any of it I told you that
story a zillion times in this podcast
I was dating this this woman
and I said I had a spot I had to go do
and it paid eight dollars at the comic
strip during the week Tuesday night I
went down there and I came back I tried
on a new bit and I was doing us and
afterwards I was at home in my apartment
and I was doing this silly dance in the
kitchen because I had a new bit and I
was psyched because I had gone through
this period where I wasn't coming up
with any new material and she was
laughing and then she got a sad look on
her face and I said what's the matter
and she said I wish I had a job
where I only got paid eight dollars yet
I came home and I did a silly dance in
the kitchen
and I never forgot that dude so that you
know what I mean you gotta have to
suffer a little bit but uh substitute
teach Uber dude you pop you got a short
story published and you got a nomination
for a literary prize come on man you
know what you're supposed to do I don't
have to go through the rest of this
[__] thing he goes my all right I'll
get to the whole thing
he said
you know part of me fights against the
dream and insists that I have to do the
responsible thing and keep teaching [__]
all of that
[__] all the responsible thing to do is
to listen to your heart
uh my question for you either in your
either in your career when you were
trying to build an audience and make it
as a stand-up comedian did you struggle
with the financial strain of chasing
your dream did you ever have to choose
between a good paying job or doing
stand-up
her heart how hard was it to work at a
shitty job just so you could Chase your
dream did you ever think that maybe you
were wasting your time any advice or
encourage I think I answered all of
those
um it wasn't hard to work at the shitty
job because I was always thinking about
the exciting job I was going to do
afterwards
um
and every night that I just went up on
stage and if it just went moderately
okay I couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe I have to be honest
with you like
I I couldn't [__] believe
that I was actually doing it that I was
actually I had a dream and I was making
it happen
and I still remember the first time I
really
went on stage and I actually
got in the zone
for what was considered a zone at the
level comic I was and I only was in the
zone for about eight seconds
um I was at Nick's comedy stop in
Framingham on route nine it doesn't even
exist anymore
and um
I just got on this roll of laughter that
I was actually able to pause
and [__] be in the moment and enjoy
it rather than be like oh my God what's
my next joke what's my next joke
and um
that [__] feeling can carry you
through a [__] shitty job for a week
chasing to get back on stage to feel
that again and then the first time I got
five dollars for gas money Freddy Stone
I've told all these stories Freddie
Stone the excitable boy
it's what he went by
um I did a room for him and he gave me
five dollars gas money I probably spent
10 to get there and I couldn't [__]
believe it
and I was like I did that and they gave
me this I couldn't [__] believe it
at what point just listen to the sound
of my voice as I'm talking about this
have you ever had that level of
excitement
doing any other [__] job that's what
it's like when you're you you go after a
dream job
so
nothing
nothing is worse than not going after it
okay and doing the responsible thing and
all of that type of [__] and then you
sit in your house with all your
responsible stuff
[__] all of that
is financially I did not do the
responsible thing and yeah I I I've said
all these stories I [__] used to eat
spaghetti every [__] night with the
can of [__] Prego
and then a bunch of bread and I would
just fill myself up on that or I go to
Denny's and I get the five stack of
pancakes and just poured my stomach like
concrete so I wouldn't have to eat the
whole [__] day and do stand up in
some cafeteria at some [__] College
and quitting never entered my mind I
just kept trying to get better at
because
as bad as some of those gigs were the
great ones were way better so
you'll have all of these stories just in
a literary way so with without a doubt
you have to [__] do it and
um
I can tell you right now man like with
what you what you've already
accomplished
like to me I would be thinking like
I'm gonna I can affect way more people
and make way more [__] money and live
a [__] dream being a professional
right I mean right I mean that'd be
unbelievable be unbelievable so not to
say there's anything wrong with teaching
but if teaching isn't your dream that's
just the job you're doing so I'm not
[__] on teachers out there it's one
of the most underrated jobs and of
course most underpaid jobs ever
um but I'm just trying to amp you up
here so
go out and [__] do it and email me
when you get published because uh I
think you're gonna I don't think you you
know
look if you're a bunch up again bunch of
other [__] writers and you won one thing
but you got two things going on here all
right give me a [__] break
all right you just need to push yourself
out of the [__] Bush not the bush the
nest
push
that was oddly gross all right that's
the [__] podcast for this week
um oh this [__] burrito [__] with
me look at the hiccups what did I do
um back on the horse back in the horse
back in the horse all right go to the
gym every day
and if you don't want me go to gym every
day you cut all right hit the gym hard
go after your dreams go [__] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday see ya